It's not the territory The code is not the man We're building as fast as we can Is it a disease? Hey guys, it's Joel with the Tapir Therapy Therapy Collective podcast, and this is a follow-up to the podcast that is the DSM dying. A lot of people ask a lot of questions
这不是领土，代码不是人，我们正以最快的速度构建，这是一种疾病吗？嘿，大家好，我是 Tapir Therapy Therapy Collective 播客的乔尔，这是对《DSM 正在消亡吗？》这一期播客的后续报道。很多人问了很多问题
That were good questions And wanted kind of a deeper dive into that So a little bit of a retread, but also a different way of looking at the thing. So let's go ahead and get started. So, you know, what happened when you, one of the things that I didn't do in the first one was back up to the idea of what a diagnosis is. You know, some people kind of had a question that sounds simple, but it's a deceptive simplicity. So, you know, before there were psychiatrists, there's priests and shamans, and there were no diagnostic manuals.
这些都是很好的问题，大家想深入了解一下，所以这算是一次重温，但也提供了一种看待这件事的不同方式。那么，让我们开始吧。你知道，当你……我在第一期节目中没有做的一件事，就是回顾诊断到底是什么。你知道，有些人提出的问题听起来很简单，但这种简单具有欺骗性。所以，你知道，在精神科医生出现之前，有牧师和萨满，那时并没有诊断手册。
They were just mythology. And ancient Greeks had this word for what we know called mental illness, and it was mania. But mania didn't mean what we mean by it. when Dionysius drove the women of Thebes to tear King Penthus, Lim from Lim, which is kind of a Greek play, if you haven't read it, about repression, that when you don't honor the gods in these temples, they go underground, and they come up through nature, and they come up through the hearts of women, and they come up through the blindness of men.
他们只有神话。古希腊人有一个词来形容我们现在所知的精神疾病，那就是“狂躁”（mania）。但“狂躁”的意思与我们现在的理解不同。当狄俄尼索斯驱使底比斯的妇女将彭透斯国王撕成碎片时——如果你没读过的话，这是一部关于压抑的希腊戏剧——当你不尊重这些神庙里的神灵时，他们就会转入地下，通过自然显现，通过女人的心显现，通过男人的盲目显现。
Or, you know, when Ajax slaughtered a flock of sheep believing them to be his enemies, because he had been bewitched. This was mania, you know, it was something that came from heaven. when the Oracle at Delphi spoke in tongues and she was possessed by Apollo, that was this kind of divine madness. And so there was this truth in madness. They understood this unconscious was this thing underneath the world that could drive you mad, but also was sort of the source of life. You know, there's that ability to hold that tension in Greek mythology. But this is alien, of course, to any modern sensibility.
或者，你知道，当埃阿斯屠杀了一群羊，认为它们是他的敌人，因为他被施了魔法。这就是“狂躁”，你知道，这是来自天堂的东西。当德尔斐的神谕者说方言，被阿波罗附身时，那就是一种神圣的疯狂。因此，疯狂中存在着某种真理。他们明白，这种潜意识是世界之下的一种东西，既能让你发疯，也是生命的一种源泉。你知道，希腊神话中有那种保持张力的能力。但这对任何现代感官来说当然是陌生的。
Half of you guys listening are probably like, you know, what the hell is that? But it is important to go back to the beginning. And so if you believed that hearing voices meant that a God was trying to tell you something or that you had been touched by a God, your entire approach to treatment would be different. You wouldn't try and make the voices stop. You'd try and figure out what they were saying, what the purpose was. You know, you might fast or you might pray or gone pilgrimage. And it's not a disorder in the way that we understand now. It's not the diagnosis, you know, but that is the origin of diagnosis.
听节目的你们有一半人可能在想，这到底是什么鬼？但回到起点很重要。所以，如果你相信听到声音意味着神在试图告诉你什么，或者你被神触碰过，那么你整个的治疗方法就会不同。你不会试图让声音停止。你会试图弄清楚它们在说什么，目的是什么。你知道，你可能会禁食、祈祷或去朝圣。这不像我们现在理解的那样是一种障碍。这不是诊断，你知道，但这正是诊断的起源。
And, you know, around the 5th century, BC, you see something shift. There's these Hippocratic physicians all of a sudden. the founders of Western medicine, and they start arguing that madness is not divine. It's just natural. They see patterns that certain families are affected. They see patterns that certain drugs, certain behaviors are associated with it, and they start to say, hey, this isn't divine. And they start to say it's a disorder of one of the four humors, you know, blood, flim, yellow bile, or black bile. It must be some substance within you, not something coming from heaven. And the famous, you know, Hippocratic Oath, or is still used in medicine.
而且，你知道，大约在公元前 5 世纪，你看到了一些变化。突然出现了希波克拉底医生，西方医学的奠基人，他们开始争辩说疯狂不是神圣的。它只是自然的。他们观察到某些家族会受到影响的模式。他们观察到某些药物、某些行为与此相关的模式，他们开始说，嘿，这不是神圣的。他们开始说这是四种体液之一的紊乱，你知道，血液、粘液、黄胆汁或黑胆汁。它一定是你体内的某种物质，而不是来自天堂的东西。还有著名的希波克拉底誓言，至今仍用于医学。
You know, it goes back to this tradition. But, you know, in one of the Hippocratic texts, the author is talking about how people shouldn't attribute seizures to gods. It used to be like a scene as this good thing. He said, you know, it's not any more divine or sacred than any other disease. Like when you get the flu in your body, why do you think that that doesn't come from a God? But when you get a disease in your mind, do you think it does? You know, that was what some of the Hippocratic texts are, you know, angry about.
你知道，这可以追溯到这个传统。但是，你知道，在希波克拉底的一篇文献中，作者谈到了人们不应该把癫痫归咎于神。它过去被视为一件好事。他说，你知道，它并不比任何其他疾病更神圣或神圣。就像当你身体患流感时，为什么你认为那不是来自神？但当你精神患病时，你却认为它是？你知道，这就是一些希波克拉底文献所愤怒的地方。
And so there's this revolution by relocating madness from heaven to the body. The Hippocratics, they created this conceptual space for medicine. But they note this that what we keep is this idea of the patient's condition meaning something. Humors weren't just chemicals. They're connected to seasons, elements, temperaments. It was seen as something that you also were participating in with your makeup. Some of that could lead to illness, but you had a tendency to black bile or yellow bile. You know, black bile meant you were melancholic.
因此，通过将疯狂从天堂转移到身体，发生了一场革命。希波克拉底学派创造了这个医学的概念空间。但他们注意到，我们保留的是患者的状况具有某种意义的想法。体液不仅仅是化学物质。它们与季节、元素、气质相连。它被视为你也参与其中的东西，与你的构成有关。其中一些可能导致疾病，但你有黑胆汁或黄胆汁的倾向。你知道，黑胆汁意味着你忧郁。
There was something in you, but also you weren't managing it well because you were, you know, being melancholic. And, you know, that had this kind of particularly prescient idea of there's something in the environment and there's also something in the person. And this humor system, you know, is what Western medicine sort of assumed for 2,000 years. And medieval physicians worked on this thing that, you know, Greeks came up with. And even up to the Renaissance, people were still saying, you know, bloodletting works because it's letting out the bad blood and basing things on it. So that's a long, long time to go from ancient Greece to the Renaissance. And then you have, you know, Descartes, when the Enlightenment happens,
你体内有某种东西，但你也没有处理好它，因为你，你知道，变得忧郁了。而且，你知道，这有一种特别有先见之明的想法，即环境中存在某种东西，人身上也存在某种东西。这种体液系统，你知道，是西方医学两千年来所假设的。中世纪的医生研究希腊人提出的这个东西。甚至到了文艺复兴时期，人们仍然在说，你知道，放血有效，因为它放出了坏血，并以此为基础。所以从古希腊到文艺复兴，这是一个非常漫长的过程。然后你有，你知道，笛卡尔，当启蒙运动发生时，
and Descartes is sort of famous for devising reality as that there's, you know, thinking stuff. and then there's extended stuff. He creates this philosophical puzzle that we still haven't solved, and he says a body is a machine operating according to mechanical laws, but the mind was something else. You know, it was this ghost in the machine. It was immaterial and indivisible and free, but also in control of it and fundamentally tethered to it.
笛卡尔因将现实划分为“思维之物”和“广延之物”而闻名。他创造了一个我们至今尚未解决的哲学难题，他说身体是一台按照机械定律运行的机器，但心灵是另一回事。你知道，它是机器里的幽灵。它是非物质的、不可分割的、自由的，但也控制着它，并从根本上与它相连。
So this dualism made science possible, because he declared that the body was pure mechanism, and it gave Descartes permission to dissect, measure, and experiment on it without worrying about the. soul. But it created this massive problem for psychiatry. Because if the mind is immaterial, how can it be sick? You know, if mental illness is real, where is it located? You know, Jung was obsessed with finding the Psycheoma, the place where the psyche met the meat, if you will, where the deepest roots of the unconscious sort of turned into bodily reactions. And the 19th century tried
所以这种二元论使科学成为可能，因为他宣称身体是纯粹的机制，这让笛卡尔有权解剖、测量和实验它，而不必担心灵魂。但这给精神病学带来了巨大的问题。因为如果心灵是非物质的，它怎么会生病呢？你知道，如果精神疾病是真实的，它位于哪里？你知道，荣格痴迷于寻找“心灵体”（Psycheoma），也就是心灵与肉体相遇的地方，如果你愿意的话，也就是潜意识最深处的根源转化为身体反应的地方。19 世纪尝试了
these different answers. You know, phrenologists thought that mental faculties were low-dicated in specific brain regions, and you could feel them through the the skull. So somebody had bad character if their skull bulged out here, good character if it had done it in here. A lot of that was just sort of saying that like people that are attractive traditionally tend to be better, um, yeah, mental, you know, a lot of phrodology just says, like, if you're hot, you're healthy, basically. Um, and so asylum doctors look for brain lesions and deceased patients. Maybe there's a wound, but it's on the mind. Um, and then the results were kind of disappointing. You couldn't quite cut somebody open and find what had made them
这些不同的答案。你知道，颅相学家认为心理能力位于大脑的特定区域，你可以通过头骨感觉到它们。所以如果某人的头骨在这里隆起，他的性格就不好，如果在这里隆起，性格就好。其中很多只是在说，传统上更有吸引力的人往往更好，嗯，是的，心理，你知道，很多颅相学只是说，如果你长得好看，你基本上就健康。嗯，所以收容所的医生在死者身上寻找脑损伤。也许有一个伤口，但它是在心灵上。嗯，结果有点令人失望。你不能在某人活着的时候切开他们，找到是什么让他们
mentally ill while they were alive. So many conditions that looked like diseases such as melancholia and hysteria, neurasthenia, they seem to have no physical basis at all. And so this is this kind of secret that still haunts psychiatry. And the modern psychiatric diagnosis was essentially invented by one man. And that's Craplin. You know, Emil Kraeplin is a German psychiatrist working in the late 19th century, early 20th century. And Craplin's intervention was that it was, he stopped trying to find the cause of the mental illness and he focused instead on the course. What's it going to do? He realized that when you get bipolar, you're not just going to go do one thing like the flu is going to make you do. It's going to have a prognosis, like a course of progression and then
精神失常。所以许多看起来像疾病的状况，如忧郁症、歇斯底里、神经衰弱，似乎根本没有身体基础。所以这就是困扰精神病学的秘密。而现代精神病学诊断本质上是由一个人发明的。那就是克雷佩林。你知道，埃米尔·克雷佩林是 19 世纪末 20 世纪初的一位德国精神科医生。克雷佩林的干预在于，他停止寻找精神疾病的起因，转而关注病程。它会怎么样？他意识到当你患上双相情感障碍时，你不会像流感那样只做一件事。它会有一个预后，就像一个进展过程，然后
decline or stagnation or whatever it does, and that we should start thinking of this as a process. So he spent decades observing patients in asylums, tracking symptoms, and he noticed that certain clusters of symptoms tended to hang together and then follow these predictable trajectories. So some patients got sick young and they deteriorated steadily and then never recovered. Others had episodes of illness followed by periods of relative health. And from these observations, Craplin carved out two categories that still structure psychiatry today. Dementia Precox, which is what Young and Freud and early psychoanalyst would have called
衰退或停滞，无论它做什么，我们应该开始把它看作一个过程。所以他花了数十年时间观察收容所的病人，追踪症状，他注意到某些症状群往往会聚在一起，然后遵循这些可预测的轨迹。所以有些病人年轻时就病了，他们稳步恶化，然后从未康复。其他人有疾病发作，随后是相对健康的时期。通过这些观察，克雷佩林划分出了两个至今仍构建精神病学的类别。早发性痴呆，也就是荣格、弗洛伊德和早期精神分析学家所称的
schizophrenia, which basically means, you know, hallucination and split from reality. And then manic depressive illness, which was later split into bipolar disorder. and major depression. And his methods were not purely descriptive. He didn't claim to know what caused it. He just was charting kind of what it was doing. He stopped trying to find a location for it, you know, a substance or wound that was happening. He just said, hey, look, when we see this symptom, we know that later it's going to be accompanied
精神分裂症，这基本上意味着，你知道，幻觉和与现实的分裂。然后是躁郁症，后来被拆分为双相情感障碍和重度抑郁症。他的方法并非纯粹的描述性。他并不声称知道是什么引起的。他只是在记录它在做什么。他停止寻找它的位置，你知道，正在发生的物质或伤口。他只是说，嘿，看，当我们看到这个症状时，我们知道以后它会伴随
by all these other symptoms because that's what everyone else did, and so we can prepare for them. So before Spitzer, you know, that we talked about in the first one, you have, you know, Freud, and whatever else you want to And whatever else you want to say about Freud, he understood something that the DSM now, modern DSM has forgotten. Symptoms are not just problems to be eliminated. There are solutions to deeper problems that mean something. So Freud's great insight that has been validated over years by trauma research is that, you know, even the specific theories of everything going back to a sexual route because of sexual selection,
所有这些其他症状，因为其他人也是这样做的，所以我们可以为它们做准备。所以在我们第一期谈到的斯皮策之前，你有，你知道，弗洛伊德，以及你想说的任何关于弗洛伊德的话。无论你想说弗洛伊德什么，他都明白了一些现代 DSM 已经忘记的事情。症状不仅仅是要消除的问题。它们是更深层问题的解决方案，具有某种意义。所以弗洛伊德的伟大洞察力，多年来已被创伤研究验证，即，你知道，即使是回到性选择的万物理论，
you know, being a driver of evolution, that doesn't mean that it's the determinism of everything in psychology like Freud thought. We've discarded that. But that psychological symptoms often have, they represent a return of experience that couldn't be processed when they occurred, which is what we'd call trauma now. You couldn't feel it because it was overwhelming. And so you shut down and it got stored and stagnated and now it's still interrupting or present this past event. You know, that would be like historical paralysis or I'm sorry, hysterical paralysis, something that they would diagnose you with back then, that you had been paralyzed in your hysteria then. and that was making you tend towards hysteria now and the present. So here's something that should be a scandal, but somehow it's not.
你知道，作为进化的驱动力，这并不意味着它是心理学中一切的决定论，就像弗洛伊德认为的那样。我们已经抛弃了这一点。但心理症状往往代表了无法在发生时处理的经验的回归，这就是我们现在所说的创伤。你无法感受到它，因为它太令人难以承受了。所以你关闭了它，它被储存起来并停滞不前，现在它仍然在打断或呈现这个过去的事件。你知道，那就像历史性的瘫痪，或者对不起，歇斯底里性瘫痪，那是他们当时会诊断你的东西，你在歇斯底里中瘫痪了，而这让你在现在倾向于歇斯底里。所以这里有一件本应是丑闻的事情，但不知何故却不是。
The DSM didn't really come from hospitals or research universities at all. That wasn't its origin. It emerged from the U.S. Army needing to process soldiers during World War II. It was a processing tool. The military had millions of young men that were being drafted, and a significant percentage of them were cracking under the stress of combat. And so the army needed to figure out who was fit for duty, who should be discharged, and who was entitled to a pension, you know, who deserved it, who fought well, but then the war
DSM 根本不是来自医院或研究型大学。那不是它的起源。它源于二战期间美国陆军处理士兵的需要。它是一个处理工具。军队有数百万年轻人被征召入伍，其中很大一部分人在战斗压力下崩溃了。所以军队需要弄清楚谁适合服役，谁应该退伍，谁有权领取养老金，你知道，谁应得的，谁打得好，但后来战争
had actually wounded them versus somebody who came in and they just were mentally ill, and then they went to war and they got discharged because they were mentally ill, but they always were. You have to screen people before, if you want to prove that it's the war that actually hurt them. So they needed codes, and they couldn't afford 500 psychiatrists that are writing these long essays about soldiers' childhood and making an individual determination. And so the solution was this technical medical bulletin number 203 issued by the War Department in 1943, and this document created this standardized nomenclature for psychiatric conditions. The first time that American psychiatry had anything like a common language.
实际上伤害了他们，而不是那些进来时就患有精神疾病，然后去打仗，因为他们患有精神疾病而退伍，但他们一直都是这样的人。如果你想证明是战争真正伤害了他们，你必须事先筛选人。所以他们需要代码，他们负担不起 500 名精神科医生写这些关于士兵童年的长篇论文并做出个人决定。所以解决方案是 1943 年战争部发布的这份技术医疗公告第 203 号，这份文件为精神疾病创造了这种标准化的命名法。这是美国精神病学第一次拥有类似通用语言的东西。
And after the war, the Veterans Administration adopted it. And when the American Psychiatric Association decided to create a unified diagnostic manual in 1952, they just copied the medical document 203, and then they made small modifications. So that's the origin story of the DSM 1. So it's not a hospital or laboratory. It's a military bureaucracy that is doing logistics. And Theodore Porter, the philosopher I talk about, and he's a historian of science. And he wrote, you know, trusted numbers.
战后，退伍军人管理局采用了它。当美国精神医学学会在 1952 年决定创建一本统一的诊断手册时，他们只是复制了医疗文件 203，然后做了小的修改。所以这就是 DSM 1 的起源故事。所以它不是医院或实验室。它是一个正在进行后勤工作的军事官僚机构。西奥多·波特，我谈到的哲学家，他是科学史学家。他写道，你知道，信任数字。
He'll come up a couple times. But this kind of proves his central thesis to most of his stuff, which is mechanical objectivity, rigid rules, checklist, standardized codes. Those are used by this not the strongest science. but the weakest ones who need to defend themselves against other bureaucrats. You know, people who are doing hard science tend not to like those. So Porter argues that we reach for numbers and rigid rules, bureaucracy, essentially, when we don't trust the people doing the work. So a village doctor who has to know his patient for 30 years doesn't need a checklist.
他会提到几次。但这证明了他大部分作品的核心论点，即机械客观性、僵化的规则、清单、标准化代码。这些不是最强大的科学所使用的，而是最弱的科学所使用的，因为他们需要保护自己免受其他官僚的侵害。你知道，做硬科学的人往往不喜欢这些。所以波特认为，当我们不信任做这项工作的人时，我们就会伸手去拿数字和僵化的规则，本质上就是官僚主义。所以一个必须了解病人 30 年的乡村医生不需要清单。
He needs his judgment, his intuition, his relationship, and we trust him because we know him. But the army couldn't just trust thousands of random psychiatrists drafted from all over the country. Some might be incompetent. some might be too soft, giving out discharges to anybody. Some might be too harsh. The Army needed a system that would produce the same result regardless of who was using it. They needed to police the doctors, not diagnose the patient. So this is what the checklist accomplishes.
他需要他的判断、他的直觉、他的关系，我们信任他，因为我们了解他。但军队不能只信任从全国各地征召的成千上万名随机的精神科医生。有些人可能不称职，有些人可能太软弱，给任何人发放退伍证明。有些人可能太严厉。军队需要一个无论谁使用都能产生相同结果的系统。他们需要监管医生，而不是诊断病人。所以这就是清单所完成的事情。
It removes judgment from the equation, or that's been the ideal for, you know, 30 years that we still have failed to get. If the patient meets criteria A, B, and C, then they have the disorder, regardless of however the doctor feels. And the DSM is not a tool for understanding patients. It is a tool for standardizing the behavior of clinicians. So Porter puts it this way. Quantification is a technology of distance.
它消除了等式中的判断，或者这是 30 年来我们仍然未能实现的理想。如果病人符合标准 A、B 和 C，那么他们就有这种障碍，无论医生感觉如何。DSM 不是一个了解病人的工具。它是一个标准化临床医生行为的工具。所以波特这样说。量化是一种距离技术。
This is a phrase he says a whole lot. And it allows a general or a bureaucrat to manage thousands of people that they'll never meet. And it makes the messy subjective world suffering of human suffering compatible with the rigid objective machinery of the state. Porter looks at basically bureaucracy as being a result of empire. When you have more territory than one person can manage, when the king can't just say, hey, go to the north wall and tell the guards to do this,
这是一个他经常说的短语。它允许将军或官僚管理成千上万他们从未见过的人。它使混乱的主观人类痛苦世界与国家僵化的客观机器相兼容。波特基本上将官僚主义视为帝国的结果。当你拥有的领土超过一个人所能管理的范围时，当国王不能只是说，嘿，去北墙告诉守卫这样做，
and then somebody does, when you have to have satraps or generals or commandants or like whoever doing these territories, and you don't trust them about how much taxes are coming. So they have to keep these records, and then multiple people have to keep the records, and the records have to agree. And something has to detect
然后有人做了，当你必须有总督或将军或指挥官或无论谁在管理这些领土时，而你不信任他们关于税收是多少。所以他们必须保存这些记录，然后多个人必须保存记录，并且记录必须一致。而且必须有某种东西来检测
if five people said that this much tax was recorded, but one guy said there wasn't. Maybe he's stealing. Empire in the ancient world is when you get bureaucracy. And it's also the origin of writing itself, because the origin of writing itself wasn't to, like, write a book. The origin of writing was people making little marks in, like, mud tablets to keep track of, like, how much they had bought and sold at a market.
如果五个人说记录了这么多税，但一个人说没有。也许他在偷窃。古代世界的帝国就是你得到官僚主义的时候。这也是写作本身的起源，因为写作本身的起源并不是为了，比如，写一本书。写作的起源是人们在泥板上做小标记，以跟踪他们在市场上买了多少和卖了多少。
It was trade. And so, you know, if you read the DSM1 with fresh eyes, you'll notice something uncomfortable. It's just completely saturated with assumptions of mid-century American Empire. You know, homosexuality is seen as sociopathic. Women are seen as hysterical. It has a lot of implicit racial assumptions that are pretty bad. And this is what I mean, you know, when I say that it's imperial.
那是贸易。所以，你知道，如果你用全新的眼光阅读 DSM1，你会注意到一些不舒服的事情。它完全被世纪中叶美帝国主义的假设所饱和。你知道，同性恋被视为反社会。女性被视为歇斯底里。它有很多隐含的种族假设，非常糟糕。这就是我的意思，你知道，当我说它是帝国主义的时候。
It's written by a small group of white men who took their worldview as the default human condition. So they were healthy and everybody else was weird or mentally ill. And they built a system for categorizing from a norm that was never examined because it didn't need to be. It just was how things are, us. We order everything else is chaos. And if we look inside the closed doors of the committees for the DSM 1 and 2, the vibe wasn't military processing at all. It was this gentleman's club. The controversies inside those rooms weren't about data or NDAs like they are now.
它是由一小群白人男性编写的，他们将自己的世界观视为默认的人类状况。所以他们是健康的，而其他人是奇怪的或精神失常的。他们建立了一个分类系统，其标准从未被审查，因为它不需要。它只是事情本来的样子，我们。我们命令其他一切都是混乱。如果我们看看 DSM 1 和 2 委员会的闭门会议，氛围根本不是军事处理。这是一个绅士俱乐部。那些房间里的争议不是关于数据或 NDA，像现在这样。
They were just these intellectual brawls between conflicting philosophies because everybody, some people were Jungian, some were Adlerian, some were Freudians, some were Freudians. And they thought that the origin and etiology of mental illness was different. So they had to find the places where they all agreed in a subjective way. They had to convince each other in a debate. And it was a small enough group that they could actually find a consensus. So the biggest controversy inside the DSM-1 committee was that the people writing a book didn't really believe in diagnosis at all, but yet they're writing a diagnostic and statistic manual.
它们只是冲突哲学之间的智力斗殴，因为每个人，有些人是荣格派，有些人是阿德勒派，有些人是弗洛伊德派。他们认为精神疾病的起源和病因不同。所以他们必须以主观的方式找到他们都同意的地方。他们必须在辩论中说服对方。而且这是一个足够小的群体，他们实际上可以达成共识。所以 DSM-1 委员会内部最大的争议是，写书的人根本不相信诊断，但他们却在写一本诊断和统计手册。
The main figure who, with the one, is Adolf Meyer, and he was seen as the Dean of American Psychiatry at the time. He hated labels. He believed every patient was a unique biosa-psocial story. And on one side, you had the Census Bureau who wanted these distinct bodies. schizophrenia, manic depressive, to count people, and it was the job of psychiatry to give them an inventory of what type of mental illness, how much, where, you know, all the stuff that the census wants. And on the other side, you had the, you know, Myrians who, you know, Adolf Myers people, who are arguing that putting a label on a patient was an insult to their complexity. And they did not want to complete the assignment they had been given, but they felt like if it was done by someone else, it would be done worse.
主要人物，也就是那个，是阿道夫·迈耶，他当时被视为美国精神病学的院长。他讨厌标签。他相信每个病人都是一个独特的生物-心理-社会故事。一方面，你有想要这些不同身体的普查局，精神分裂症，躁郁症，来计算人数，而精神病学的工作是给他们一个精神疾病类型的清单，多少，在哪里，你知道，普查想要的所有东西。另一方面，你有，你知道，迈耶派，你知道，阿道夫·迈耶的人，他们争辩说给病人贴标签是对他们复杂性的侮辱。他们不想完成他们被分配的任务，但他们觉得如果由别人来做，会做得更糟。
So the committee solved this by adding the word reaction to everything that psychiatrists were saying. So you didn't have schizophrenia as a disease. You had it as a reaction. It was a temporary response. It might go away. Some people become psychotic and then it leaves. And so this was this philosophical coup where it codified everything saying that mental illness was not inside the brain, but it was a reaction to the world.
所以委员会通过在精神科医生所说的一切后面加上“反应”这个词解决了这个问题。所以你没有作为疾病的精神分裂症。你把它作为一种反应。这是一种暂时的反应。它可能会消失。有些人变得精神病，然后它就离开了。所以这是一场哲学政变，它编纂了一切，说精神疾病不在大脑内，而是对世界的反应。
And so it was sort of this victory of, you know, the system or the environment over biology, just the individual biology of the person causing everything. But there was also this power play, the chair of the D.O. one committee wasn't a doctor he was a brigadier general and he had run psychiatry for the US Army during World War II and developed Medical 203 the manual he made it so that really is the DSM you know before it's called that you know one point or I don't know one point of 0.5 you know it's the beta version and for the civilian academics these East Coast elites resented the military encroaching on their turf they viewed the military system as too crude but you know
所以这在某种程度上是，你知道，系统或环境对生物学的胜利，不仅仅是人个人的生物学导致了一切。但这里也有一场权力游戏，DSM 1 委员会的主席不是医生，他是一位准将，他在二战期间管理过美国陆军的精神病学，并开发了医疗 203 手册，他使它成为真正的 DSM，你知道，在它被称为那个之前，你知道，一点或我不知道一点零点五，你知道，它是测试版，对于平民学者来说，这些东海岸精英对军队侵犯他们的地盘感到不满，他们认为军事系统太粗糙，但你知道
Menninger won because he had the prestige of the war victory. And the DSM1 is largely just this copy and paste of the Army's Medical 203 with reaction added to all the diagnoses. So it didn't change that much. The first version was really the second version. When we get to the second version, the DSM2, that's 1968. And they're fighting this new war, which is globalism. Europe has their own thing.
门宁格赢了，因为他有战争胜利的声望。而 DSM1 在很大程度上只是军队医疗 203 的复制粘贴，并在所有诊断中添加了“反应”。所以它没有改变那么多。第一个版本实际上是第二个版本。当我们到达第二个版本，DSM2 时，那是 1968 年。他们正在打这场新战争，即全球主义。欧洲有他们自己的东西。
The World Health Organization is using the ICD8, because they're also needing data to try and figure out who needs what where and what problems are happening and what problems are going away. And they were kind of telling Americans, like, stop using all this weird Freudian language, like align with the West of the world, just say they have anxiety or depression. And inside this committee, stop saying neurosis, you know, what does that mean? Does that mean they're anxious or does that mean they're depressed? What does neurotic mean?
世界卫生组织正在使用 ICD8，因为他们也需要数据来试图弄清楚谁在哪里需要什么，发生了什么问题，什么问题正在消失。他们有点在告诉美国人，像，停止使用所有这些奇怪的弗洛伊德语言，像与世界西方保持一致，只说他们有焦虑或抑郁。在这个委员会内部，停止说神经症，你知道，那是什么意思？那意味着他们焦虑还是意味着他们抑郁？神经症是什么意思？
And so these internationalists, they wanted to adopt the European ICD system or not system, but the terms. They want to take ICD terms, join with the rest of the world. Everyone's roughly on the same page. American psychiatry can still do its own thing. And it was a lot more biological, though, because it was made from the World Health Organization basically to study outbreaks, to study pathology of viruses and things like that. And so the American Freudians refused to give up neurosis and hysteria.
所以这些国际主义者，他们想采用欧洲的 ICD 系统或不是系统，而是术语。他们想采用 ICD 术语，与世界其他地方联合起来。每个人大致都在同一页上。美国精神病学仍然可以做自己的事情。而且它更生物学，因为它基本上是由世界卫生组织制作的，用来研究爆发，研究病毒等的病理学。所以美国弗洛伊德派拒绝放弃神经症和歇斯底里。
They really liked it. And they argued that the European psychiatry was superficial. It just wasn't going as deep because it wasn't approaching the unconscious mind, which I don't think was true of European psychiatry, but it was definitely true of the ICD-8, because the ICD8 was just trying to come up with a whole list of bad stuff that can happen to health in your country and then let you have a list of it, which is probably a bad manual to adopt for psychiatry. So the committee spent months arguing over the word hysteria, and the Europeans had banned it.
他们真的很喜欢它。他们争辩说欧洲精神病学是肤浅的。它只是没有深入，因为它没有接近潜意识，我不认为这对欧洲精神病学是真实的，但这对 ICD-8 绝对是真实的，因为 ICD8 只是试图列出一整套可能发生在你国家的健康坏事，然后让你有一个清单，这可能是一本不适合精神病学采用的手册。所以委员会花了几个月时间争论“歇斯底里”这个词，而欧洲人已经禁止了它。
They called it antiquated, and the Americans insisted on keeping it. So they decided to keep hysterical neurosis in the two. And to appease the American analysts, making the U.S. you know, look kind of scientifically backward to Europe. They keep this, but Europe judges us, and there's kind of a split. And the biggest difference between these committees and the later ones was this complete lack of data. You know, they didn't run trials. They sent out letters to prominent psychiatrists asking, what do you think?
他们称它为过时的，而美国人坚持保留它。所以他们决定在 2 中保留歇斯底里性神经症。为了安抚美国分析师，使美国，你知道，在欧洲人看来有点科学落后。他们保留了这个，但欧洲评判我们，并且有一种分裂。这些委员会与后来委员会之间最大的区别是完全缺乏数据。你知道，他们没有进行试验。他们给著名的精神科医生发信询问，你怎么看？
For the DSM2, they surveyed 12,000 psychiatrists and only 10% wrote back. And the committee shrugged and was like, okay, we'll write what we think is best, and everyone who wrote back will read what they wrote and we'll try and include it. And this submitted this idea that the DSM was just opinions of a few old men in a room. And there's no real mechanism to challenge them because they claimed authority-based. on prestige that they were very rich and powerful doctors who headed prestigious universities or had prestigious practices or both. And in the 1960s, you know, everything was sort of coming into question all American institutions.
对于 DSM2，他们调查了 12,000 名精神科医生，只有 10% 回信。委员会耸耸肩，就像，好吧，我们将写下我们认为最好的，所有回信的人都会读他们写的，我们会尽量包括它。这提交了这个想法，即 DSM 只是房间里几个老人的意见。而且没有真正的机制来挑战他们，因为他们声称基于声望的权威，他们是非常富有和强大的医生，领导着著名的大学或拥有著名的诊所，或两者兼有。在 1960 年代，你知道，一切都在某种程度上受到质疑，所有美国机构。
You know, Thomas Zaz publishes the myth of mental illness in 61 and he just says it's a categorical era. The mind's not organ. It can't be sick the way the liver is sick. What we call mental illness is really just moral, social, and personal conflicts. And we've just medicalized them because we don't want to deal with the fact that our society is actually the sick one. And that becomes, you know, from Zaz, this idea that defines American psychology and charges up people like Lang and Rosenhan that we talked about before.
你知道，托马斯·萨斯在 61 年出版了《精神疾病的神话》，他只是说这是一个分类错误。心灵不是器官。它不能像肝脏那样生病。我们所说的精神疾病实际上只是道德、社会和个人冲突。我们只是将它们医疗化了，因为我们不想处理这样一个事实，即我们的社会实际上是生病的那个。这变成了，你知道，来自萨斯，这个定义美国心理学的想法，并激励了我们之前谈到的像莱恩和罗森汉这样的人。
So, you know, Rosenhan we talked about in the first episode. And he's the one who got his psych patients, or so he says, you're not psych patients. He got his graduate assistance. And he said, we're all going to go in, 12 of us. And we're going to say that we heard somebody say empty hollow thud that wasn't there. and then otherwise we're going to act totally sane and we're going to watch how they think that we have schizophrenia that we're crazy and then start to record how everything that we were doing in the hospital was actually a result of our mental illness
所以，你知道，罗森汉我们在第一集谈到了。他是那个让他的精神病人，或者他所说的，你不是精神病人。他让他的研究生助手。他说，我们都要进去，我们 12 个人。我们要说我们听到有人说“空、空、砰”，那是不存在的。然后除此之外，我们要表现得完全理智，我们要观察他们如何认为我们患有精神分裂症，我们疯了，然后开始记录我们在医院里所做的一切实际上是我们精神疾病的结果
based on the way that they are choosing to categorize us and that the categories really control us and others' perceptions. They don't actually help us get to the truth of anything. So Rosenen publishes that paper and it's this kind of a scandal. And there's more to it. We already covered it in the first part.
基于他们选择分类我们的方式，以及这些类别实际上控制了我们和他人的看法。它们并没有真正帮助我们找到任何事情的真相。所以罗森汉发表了那篇论文，这是一种丑闻。还有更多。我们已经在第一部分涵盖了它。
One of the things that I didn't say is that most people now think that Rosenhan probably made up large parts of that experiment. They found one graduate student who said that he went into the hospital and it really wasn't that bad and he had a good time. And he's the only one that they ever found. All the other students that Rosenhand worked with never said I was one of those people. Also, they got Rosenhan's actual medical records out of the hospital. And from those medical records, he said that he was suicidal and several things that would warrant an ER admission, even today. So either the doctors wrote that in there because he said empty dull thud and they just decided that he was crazy and that they needed a reason to
我没有说的一件事是，大多数人现在认为罗森汉可能编造了那个实验的很大一部分。他们发现了一名研究生，他说他进了医院，情况真的没那么糟，他玩得很开心。他是他们发现的唯一一个。罗森汉合作过的所有其他学生从未说过“我是那些人之一”。此外，他们从医院拿到了罗森汉的实际医疗记录。从那些医疗记录中，他说他有自杀倾向，即使在今天，也有几件事值得急诊入院。所以要么医生写在里面，因为他说“空、沉闷、砰”，他们只是决定他疯了，他们需要一个理由来
justify admission so they made one up and they forged the medical records that could have happened or Rosenand lied. So let's talk about why. You know, like I talk about, you know, Freud and the illusion of progress thing that he Freud lies a lot like he he says these are my neuroses and these are my case studies on myself. These are my dreams from self-analysts, but this is my private diary. It won't get published. And then he says, these are my neuroses and these are my case studies on myself. These are my dreams from self-analysts. But this is my private diary. It won't get published. And then he says, and then he says, he writes about what these patients are doing that looks really almost exactly the same like him. And he were published at his case studies to prove his theory and says he did it with a patient. But then he didn't think that his journals would be published when they were. It's like, oh, yeah, I think you really just took your own work. Freud lies in a couple places. Dr. Frederick Cruz's book is really good.
证明入院，所以他们编造了一个，他们伪造了医疗记录，这可能发生了，或者罗森汉撒谎了。所以让我们谈谈为什么。你知道，就像我谈到的，你知道，弗洛伊德和进步的幻觉，弗洛伊德撒了很多谎，像他，他说这些是我的神经症，这些是我对自己的案例研究。这些是我从自我分析中得到的梦，但这是我的私人日记。它不会被出版。然后他说，这些是我的神经症，这些是我对自己的案例研究。这些是我从自我分析中得到的梦。但这是我的私人日记。它不会被出版。然后他说，然后他说，他写了这些病人正在做的事情，看起来真的几乎和他一模一样。他出版了他的案例研究来证明他的理论，并说他是和一个病人一起做的。但后来他没想到他的日记会在出版时被出版。就像，哦，是的，我想你真的只是拿了你自己的工作。弗洛伊德在几个地方撒了谎。弗雷德里克·克鲁兹博士的书真的很好。
I won't defend him. Where I will defend Rosenhan is he was intimately acquainted with these systems. And he probably had the thing that a lot of the kind of ego in full. and mezzianic energy that a lot of these people had, which is like, dude, I don't want to wait and spend money and replicate this experiment because I see it happen like 800 times a day, and I know exactly how it works. And I just need you to believe it. Here's the Theodore Porter thing again.
我不会为他辩护。我为罗森汉辩护的地方是他对这些系统非常熟悉。他可能拥有很多那种自我膨胀和弥赛亚能量，很多人都有，那就是，伙计，我不想等待、花钱并复制这个实验，因为我每天看到它发生 800 次，我知道它到底是怎么运作的。我只需要你相信它。这是西奥多·波特的观点。
So I'm just going to throw some numbers at it that are lies because you like numbers. So I think, personally, that Rosenhand probably had seen this stuff happen over and over again, that that was happening in American psychiatry, but that he faked the science. He faked the science because he didn't think that he needed it. he wasn't really why he was in the profession he didn't respect it he was an anti-psychiatry humanitarian holistic guy um he didn't like the system so you know he's anti-authoritarian he's already seen them do these things so i wasn't recording the study then but why don't i just write this stuff down and then say that it happened because i know that i've seen it a hundred times before i think that's
所以我只是要扔一些谎言的数字给它，因为你喜欢数字。所以我个人认为，罗森汉可能已经看到这些事情一遍又一遍地发生，这在美国精神病学中正在发生，但他伪造了科学。他伪造了科学，因为他不认为他需要它。他并不是真正为什么他在这个行业，他不尊重它，他是一个反精神病学的人道主义、整体论者，嗯，他不喜欢这个系统，所以你知道，他是反权威的，他已经看到他们做这些事情，所以我当时没有记录研究，但我为什么不把这些东西写下来，然后说它发生了，因为我知道我已经见过一百次了，我认为这就是
what happened american psychiatry is kind of on trial because they're calling basically all people that are gay sociopaths which is terrible and they can't compromise on that because some of them think that homosexuality is definitely wrong because it comes from some neurotic thing in childhood that happens to you. Other people say no, it's a totally fine way for multiple, you know, for consenting partners to live in an alternative way, and it's fine. And they storm the committee for the DSM-3. They storm the committee and they go in and, you know, basically,
发生了什么，美国精神病学正在受审，因为他们基本上称所有同性恋的人为反社会者，这太可怕了，他们不能对此妥协，因为他们中的一些人认为同性恋绝对是错误的，因为它来自童年时期发生在你身上的某种神经症。其他人说不，这对于多个，你知道，对于同意的伴侣以替代方式生活是完全可以的，这很好。他们冲进了 DSM-3 的委员会。他们冲进委员会，他们进去，你知道，基本上，
make a big scene in Rosenhan, or not Rosanham, I'm sorry, Spitzer. So Spitzer is the guy who will chair the DSM 3, but I'm talking about the DSM 2, right? He's just a note taker. He's kind of been flagged as a workaholic who has a ton of energy and a lot of diligence, but it doesn't great, has a lot of great clinical, you know, rationale. And because he's not really intuitively clinical, but he likes psychiatry. He likes the numbers of it. He's the note taker for the DSM2, which is interesting. But he's the guy who stands up while the anti-psychiatry movement and the gay rights
在罗森汉，或者不是罗森汉，对不起，斯皮策那里制造了一个大场面。所以斯皮策是那个将主持 DSM 3 的人，但我说的是 DSM 2，对吧？他只是一个记录员。他被标记为一个工作狂，有大量的能量和勤奋，但它并不伟大，有很多伟大的临床，你知道，理由。而且因为他并不是真正直觉上的临床，但他喜欢精神病学。他喜欢它的数字。他是 DSM2 的记录员，这很有趣。但他是在反精神病学运动和同性恋权利运动时站起来的人
movement, early, they can call it at that time. It was Meyer, which there's an article in my blog, Myers, the psychiatrist who went and testified wearing a mask, basically, because he said, I am a gay psychiatrist. I am an effective person. I'm a rich person. I'm one of you, but I'm going to wear this mask, and I'm going to use a voice changer to testify because I don't want American psychiatry to know who I am yet. I'm going to go in anonymously.
运动，早期，他们可以在那个时候称之为。那是迈耶，我的博客里有一篇文章，迈耶，那个戴着面具作证的精神科医生，基本上，因为他说，我是一名同性恋精神科医生。我是一个有效的人。我是一个富有的人。我是你们中的一员，但我会戴上这个面具，我会使用变声器来作证，因为我不想让美国精神病学知道我是谁。我会匿名进去。
And later, you know, it comes out that it was Meyer, but during this movement, these people staged this protest at the DSM2, and Spitzer's the one who stands up and brokers a compromise. He has this idea to remove homosexuality from the DSM, the APA votes, and they choose that instead, of calling it a sociopathy disorder basically categorizing it is that they call it sexual deviation that it's this thing that is deviating from the norm but it's not deviant it's just deviate
后来，你知道，它出来了，那是迈耶，但在这次运动中，这些人策划了对 DSM2 的抗议，而斯皮策是那个站起来并促成妥协的人。他有这个想法，将同性恋从 DSM 中删除，APA 投票，他们选择了那个，而不是称它为反社会障碍，基本上将其分类为性偏差，即它是偏离规范的东西，但它不是偏差，它只是偏离
and so spitzer does that but that process of them only the APL only voting in this way and then him having to deal with a group of people in the room, it's kind of the beginning of the DSM becoming a political thing that there's public interest and pressure on. And it's kind of schizophrenia that saves 1970s psychiatry in a way because the DSM2 doesn't really go far to convince anybody that it's science or that psychiatrists are doing something real. But as the really early antipsychotics start to mature,
所以斯皮策做了那个，但他们只有 APL 以这种方式投票的过程，然后他不得不处理房间里的一群人，这在某种程度上是 DSM 成为政治事物的开始，有公众利益和压力。而且在某种程度上是精神分裂症拯救了 1970 年代的精神病学，因为 DSM2 并没有真正走得太远去说服任何人它是科学，或者精神科医生正在做一些真实的事情。但随着非常早期的抗精神病药物开始成熟，
and you start to get second generation. The first generation antipsychotic is Thorazine. It's almost never used anymore. It's the one you associated with like real blunted affect drooling, but it makes you quit screaming and hallucinating. It's a very sedating medication. It's not a great antipsychotic, but it was the first one that we ever had.
你开始得到第二代。第一代抗精神病药是氯丙嗪。它几乎不再使用了。它是你与那种真正的迟钝情感、流口水联系在一起的药物，但它让你停止尖叫和产生幻觉。这是一种非常镇静的药物。它不是一种伟大的抗精神病药，但它是我们曾经拥有的第一种。
You know, I said in the 90s, everyone's obsessed with ADHD and the odds, it's autism. And then now it's kind of trauma. But in the 70s, schizophrenia represented the most broad encounter point for the public to see mental illness and the biggest expenditure of psychiatric mental health resources. And that was really furthered when the Vietnam War ends and a lot of these people come home. And a lot of these people start to take drugs. And not everyone taking drugs is in the military, but a lot of people with PTSD and the military do.
你知道，我在90年代说过，每个人都痴迷于多动症（ADHD），后来是自闭症。现在则有点像创伤。但在70年代，精神分裂症是公众接触精神疾病最广泛的切入点，也是精神卫生资源支出最大的领域。随着越战结束，许多人回国，这种情况进一步加剧。这些人中有很多开始吸毒。虽然并非所有吸毒者都来自军队，但许多患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的军人确实如此。
So, you know, and there was this idea that like really, it wasn't the drugs that created. It wasn't the mental illness. The drugs didn't create the mental illness. like you weren't just getting addicted to this addictive substance. It was that only the mentally ill would do drugs. So if you saw somebody who was raining and raving and doing drugs, they probably were just, you know, sick before and that's why this happened. So psychiatry and a lot of drug addiction or schizophrenia and drug addiction
所以，当时有一种观点认为，并不是毒品导致了精神疾病。毒品并没有创造出精神疾病。你不仅仅是因为对这种成瘾物质产生了依赖。而是只有精神病患者才会去吸毒。所以如果你看到有人在胡言乱语、吸食毒品，他们可能在之前就已经生病了，这就是为什么会发生这种情况。因此，精神病学与许多药物成瘾，或者说精神分裂症与药物成瘾，
are kind of linked together in a way that we don't do anymore. A little bit, you know, there's some stigma, but we've pushed back. You know, so Thorazine comes out in the 50s. But it takes a while for the implications of it to sink in and for it to kind of come out of the asylum into mainstream healthcare to a thing that doctors who aren't just keeping people that they're going to keep for realistically most of their life are prescribing. And so psychiatrists could now do something that it feels like magic. You know, there's all of this research in the 60s, mainly, you know, by the VA about talk
在某种程度上被联系在了一起，而这种联系我们现在已经不再这样做了。虽然还有一点点污名化，但我们已经进行了反击。你知道，50年代氯丙嗪（Thorazine）问世了。但它的影响需要一段时间才能深入人心，并从精神病院进入主流医疗保健领域，成为那些不仅仅是长期收容病人、而是真正会为病人开药的医生所使用的手段。因此，精神科医生现在可以做一些感觉像是魔法的事情。你知道，60年代有大量研究，主要是由退伍军人事务部（VA）进行的，关于
therapy and psychoanalysis for schizophrenia. Can it change somebody who is psychotic? Can you give them this root? There's all these theories of schizophrenia that comes from trauma and certain things in childhood. Can you go back and psychoanalyze those things and then cure the schizophrenia? And it turns out that you can. It's a largely endogenous illness. And Insight doesn't really help you reduce the symptoms.
精神分裂症的谈话疗法和精神分析。它能改变精神病患者吗？你能给他们这种根源吗？关于精神分裂症源于创伤和童年某些经历的理论有很多。你能回过头来对这些事情进行精神分析，然后治愈精神分裂症吗？事实证明，你做不到。这在很大程度上是一种内源性疾病。洞察力并不能真正帮助你减轻症状。
It may help you relate to the symptoms. It may help you manage them. But it doesn't really make them go away. Whereas, you know, 10 years of psychoanalysis don't work. Now we have a medication and the medication just works. And so this made psychiatry have this validity because everyone can sort of see this very valid thing that they're doing that is not, that is not deniable. Whereas something like the unconscious and,
它可能有助于你理解症状，也可能有助于你管理症状。但它并不能真正让症状消失。然而，你知道，10年的精神分析并没有奏效。现在我们有了药物，而药物确实有效。这使得精神病学具有了这种有效性，因为每个人都能看到他们所做的这种非常有效的事情，这是不可否认的。而像潜意识之类的东西，
these woo-woo concepts like those are. You can't show me them in a test tube, and I don't believe you, so I don't think they're real. So the dopamine hypothesis of schizophrenia emerges, which we now know is kind of not right, but it basically says that because we know that these drugs block dopamine, maybe too much dopamine is what's causing schizophrenia. And that's an operating assumption until about the 90s when it starts to get discredited and you get theories like the indirect pathway dysregulation and sensory gating theories and other and other theories. And so that success with schizophrenia and severe bipolar disorder became psychiatry's
这些虚无缥缈的概念，你无法在试管中向我展示它们，我不相信你，所以我认为它们不是真实的。于是，精神分裂症的多巴胺假说出现了，我们现在知道这并不完全正确，但它基本上认为，因为我们知道这些药物会阻断多巴胺，所以多巴胺过多可能是导致精神分裂症的原因。这一假设一直沿用到90年代左右，当时它开始受到质疑，并出现了间接通路失调理论、感觉门控理论以及其他理论。因此，精神分裂症和严重双相情感障碍的成功成为了精神病学的
big trump card. And it legitimized everything else. And so the logic went something like this. We can treat schizophrenia with medicine and that affects brain chemistry. Therefore, mental illness is caused by brain diseases of chemistry. And therefore, all our diagnostic care categories must correspond, not that we can see, but we're just assuming in all these categories that we made, they must correspond to real biological entities. that are somewhere. And therefore, the DSM is scientific. So notice that leap, though, the fact that the antipsychotics helpless schizophrenia doesn't prove that a major depressive disorder or a generalized anxiety disorder, you know, other types borderline personality disorder are biological entities in the same
王牌。它使其他一切都合法化了。逻辑大致是这样的：我们可以用药物治疗精神分裂症，而这会影响大脑化学物质。因此，精神疾病是由大脑化学疾病引起的。因此，我们所有的诊断类别必须对应——不是说我们能看到，而是我们假设我们制定的所有这些类别，它们一定对应于某个地方的真实生物实体。因此，DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）是科学的。但请注意这个飞跃，抗精神病药物对精神分裂症有帮助，这一事实并不能证明重度抑郁症或广泛性焦虑症，或者其他类型的边缘性人格障碍，在同样
way. That doesn't prove that. Just because you made up one category and that category is affected by medication does not mean that every single other category has this biological root in the way that they were thinking. But that it was what they were thinking and what they were writing. And so this is what saved psychiatry. It wasn't just the checklist of the DSM3. The DSM3 was an attempt to assume this harder, but it was really caused by these drugs.
的方式下也是生物实体。这并不能证明这一点。仅仅因为你编造了一个类别，而该类别受到药物的影响，并不意味着其他每一个类别都像他们所想的那样具有这种生物学根源。但这正是他们所想和所写的。这就是拯救精神病学的原因。这不仅仅是因为DSM-3的检查清单。DSM-3是试图假设这种更硬性的东西，但它实际上是由这些药物引起的。
So finally psychiatrists had something that they could prescribe. It wasn't just an addictive drug like cocaine or sedatives. And so the price of all this stuff is that we still assume that about all the die disorders in the DSM a little bit too much, just because of this one movement, you know, at this time. And so in the 1970s, psychiatry is in this existential crisis still. I'm setting the stage for the thing we talked about the first time. There's insurance companies that are starting to just refuse to pay, and the public thought psychiatrists were kind of fraud, an authoritarian, and cranky. And researchers couldn't replicate findings because
所以最终精神科医生有了可以开出的处方。这不仅仅是像可卡因或镇静剂那样的成瘾药物。这一切的代价是，我们仍然对DSM中的所有疾病假设得太多了，仅仅是因为当时的那一场运动。所以到了1970年代，精神病学仍然处于这种存在主义危机中。我正在为我们第一次谈论的事情铺路。保险公司开始拒绝支付费用，公众认为精神科医生有点像骗子、独裁者和怪人。研究人员无法重复研究结果，因为
nobody could agree on what the disorders even were and the two because they're all these subjective things. And so now Robert Spitzer is hired to chair the writing of the three, the guy who brokered the compromise that made the two. And so Spitzer is this kind of revolutionary. He's like this awkward, obsessive guy, and he's not very socially graceful. And he has skills that are largely administrative, not really clinical. And so when he's at, asking psychiatrists for their ideas. One of the reasons he ends up here is he's supposed to broker between a fight between all these psychiatrists, but he also doesn't really have a point of view because
没有人能就这些疾病到底是什么达成一致，因为它们都是主观的东西。于是，罗伯特·斯皮策（Robert Spitzer）被聘请主持第三版的编写，他就是那个促成第二版妥协的人。斯皮策是一个革命者。他是一个笨拙、强迫症的人，社交能力不强。他的技能主要在于行政管理，而非临床。所以当他向精神科医生征求意见时，他最终走到这一步的原因之一是他被要求在所有这些精神科医生之间的争斗中进行调解，但他自己并没有真正的观点，因为
he's not really a practicing psychiatrist who has an axe to grind theoretically with anyone else. He's just trying to get them to agree. And so he was too focused. He was too, you know, measure, he was focused on measurable things. And so he had been kicked upstairs into administrative role. because he didn't really have what they needed in a clinician. And then he's very successful at them.
他并不是一个在理论上与其他人有矛盾的执业精神科医生。他只是想让他们达成一致。他太专注了。他太注重可衡量的东西了。所以他被提拔到了行政职位，因为他没有临床医生所需要的东西。但他在这方面非常成功。
And so Spitzer makes his name by the DTHM2 thing, and then he's brought in and chaired to write the three. So what happens during the writing of the three is they're trying to solve that reliability crisis of why this thing isn't really very reliable. And the US-UK diagnostic project has shown that American doctors diagnose schizophrenia twice, often as British doctors for the exact same patients. So when you look at the symptoms and
所以斯皮策凭借DSM-2成名，然后被请来主持编写第三版。在编写第三版期间，他们试图解决为什么这个东西不太可靠的可靠性危机。美英诊断项目显示，美国医生诊断精神分裂症的频率是英国医生的两倍，针对的是完全相同的病人。所以当你观察症状和
then you look at the diagnosis, the people who are checking the same boxes in the U.S. are getting diagnosed differently in the U.K. So these labels mean different things and the subjective descriptions about reaction no longer work. And, you know, Spitzer was obsessed with reliability and he wanted doctors to agree. And so he had developed this research criteria that used checklists instead of vague feelings so that people could just ask the patient six questions that all patients were getting asked the same six questions and assess for the same thing. And then hopefully you end up with the same diagnosis. We know now that's not what happened, but that was the assumption at the time.
然后观察诊断时，在美国勾选相同方框的人在英国得到了不同的诊断。所以这些标签意味着不同的东西，关于反应的主观描述不再有效。而且，你知道，斯皮策痴迷于可靠性，他希望医生们达成一致。因此，他开发了使用检查清单而不是模糊感觉的研究标准，这样人们就可以问病人六个问题，所有病人都被问到相同的六个问题，并评估相同的东西。然后希望你能得到相同的诊断。我们现在知道情况并非如此，但那是当时的假设。
It's a reasonable one. So until Spitzer, the DSM is heavily influenced by Freudian psychoanalysis still. There's unconscious conflict and neuroses and depression and anger is turned inward. And there's these Freudian assumptions about how these things work. They thought that depression was a rage that was going inward towards the self, shutting it down, instead of outward towards the world. And Spitzer hates this. Like, you can't measure unconscious conflict. You can't get two analysts to agree on what's being repressed or what the event is or what they're reacting to in the environment.
这是一个合理的假设。所以直到斯皮策之前，DSM仍然深受弗洛伊德精神分析的影响。存在潜意识冲突、神经症，抑郁和愤怒转向内心。关于这些东西如何运作，存在着弗洛伊德式的假设。他们认为抑郁是一种向内指向自我的愤怒，将其关闭，而不是向外指向世界。斯皮策讨厌这一点。你无法衡量潜意识冲突。你无法让两位分析师就什么是被压抑的、事件是什么或他们对环境的反应是什么达成一致。
So the whole framework is just too wishy and it's too poetic. And so his solution was to make the DSM have no theory at all to be a theoretical. No assumptions about where the stuff comes from. Don't say why people are depressed. You just say that they are. and you give them a disorder. And so this diplomatic masterstroke allowed the Freudians and the more biological psychiatrists from like the Evo-Syck people that are coming out at this time, early versions of that,
所以整个框架太虚无缥缈，太诗意了。他的解决方案是让DSM完全没有理论，即“无理论”。不对这些东西的来源做任何假设。不要说人们为什么抑郁。你只需要说他们抑郁了，然后给他们一个诊断。这一外交上的神来之笔让弗洛伊德派和当时出现的更偏向生物学的精神科医生（如早期版本的进化心理学派），
to use the same code. They could now agree about causes and the profession could talk to each other. And so this is where it gets kind of wild, though, that I didn't say in the first one, is like Spitzer did this in a pretty chaotic way. Like everyone would get drinks. They would call them typewriter parties. Like he sits behind a keyboard typing the stuff up and then crossing it out when they're disagreeing and then typing up again. And he's yelling, okay, if a patient feels worthless on Tuesday but not on Wednesday, does that count?
能够使用相同的代码。他们现在可以就病因达成一致，专业人士之间也可以进行交流。但这就是变得有点疯狂的地方，我在第一次谈话中没有提到，斯皮策是以一种相当混乱的方式完成这件事的。每个人都会去喝酒。他们称之为“打字机派对”。他坐在键盘后面打字，当他们不同意时就划掉，然后再打一遍。他大喊：“好吧，如果一个病人周二感到毫无价值，但周三没有，这算吗？”
And half of them yell, yeah, that's depression. That's an instant. The other one's going to know, everyone goes up and down. Depression has to last six days. And then they argue. And then they say, okay, but if he feels worthless and he feels bad and he's crying, but he lost his job and he's depressed for a week. Is that a symptom or normal reaction? And then they all argue, no, that's just the environment.
一半人喊：“是的，那是抑郁。那是瞬间的。”另一半人说：“不，每个人都有起伏。抑郁必须持续六天。”然后他们争论。然后他们说：“好吧，但如果他感到毫无价值，感觉很糟糕，而且在哭，但他丢了工作，并且抑郁了一周。那是症状还是正常反应？”然后他们都争论：“不，那只是环境。”
It didn't come out of nowhere. Well, no, but the environment can make you depressed. And they fight. And then this goes on weeks, you know, while they're all just sort of getting people in a room and he's forcing them to agree. But that was his gift was that he came in, not as a scientist, but a lover of science who was more of a politician because he would sort of outside of the world that they were in. He didn't care about theory. Everyone cared about theory. And so he forced them to make these binary.
它不是凭空产生的。好吧，不，但环境会让你抑郁。他们争吵。这持续了几个星期，你知道，当他们把人关在一个房间里，他强迫他们达成一致。但他的天赋在于，他不是作为一个科学家，而是一个热爱科学的人，更像是一个政治家，因为他某种程度上处于他们所处的世界之外。他不关心理论。每个人都关心理论。所以他强迫他们做出这些二元选择：
choices of where would you draw the line? Okay, fine. What if it's two days more? What if it's this? What if there's nothing? You know, he made them come up with numbers of this amount of symptoms have to happen before I say depression. No one was thinking in that way before. No one was diagnosing like we diagnosed. They were speaking in this language just as a conceptual thing, but no one was really thinking about frequency and intensity and duration like we'd think about now. Spitzer had this other agenda that was more personal. He wanted to destroy the power of psychoanalysts. Until the three, the language of psychiatry was still Freudian, and Spitzer stripped out all the DSM-3 stuff to make it a theoretical. And then here's the thing that nobody talks about, Spitzer's method, though, like it was completely backwards as somebody who loved science from how science is supposed to work.
你会把界限画在哪里？好吧，没问题。如果是多两天呢？如果是这样呢？如果没有呢？你知道，他让他们想出多少症状必须发生我才能说抑郁。之前没有人那样想过。没有人像我们现在这样诊断。他们只是把这种语言当作一个概念性的东西，但没有人真正像我们现在这样思考频率、强度和持续时间。斯皮策还有另一个更个人的议程。他想摧毁精神分析学家的权力。在第三版之前，精神病学的语言仍然是弗洛伊德式的，斯皮策删除了DSM-3中所有的东西，使其成为无理论的。然后这里有一件事没人谈论，斯皮策的方法，虽然作为一个热爱科学的人，这与科学应该运作的方式完全背道而驰。
Because the scientific ideal would be to gather data first. You would observe thousands of patients, record all the symptoms, and then you would use statistics to group those symptoms together and see where they co-occur. and then the patient's data is telling you what the diagnosis is. What they did with the DSM3 was they said, hey, here's these diagnoses. What are the symptoms for them? So maybe you discover if you did the data that way. Well, everyone who calls depression,
因为科学理想应该是先收集数据。你会观察成千上万的病人，记录所有症状，然后使用统计数据将这些症状分组，看看它们在哪里同时出现。然后病人的数据会告诉你诊断结果是什么。他们用DSM-3做的是，他们说：“嘿，这些是诊断。它们的症状是什么？”所以也许如果你那样做数据，你会发现。好吧，每个称自己抑郁的人，
who says they're depressed or who's been called depressed, it's actually three different conditions that need different names because these people are anxious, these people, it's a life event. But they didn't do that. They said, hey, depression exists. We know that. that's self-evident. So what are the symptoms of it?
或者被称为抑郁的人，实际上是三种不同的情况，需要不同的名称，因为这些人焦虑，这些人是生活事件。但他们没有那样做。他们说：“嘿，抑郁症存在。我们知道这一点。这是不言而喻的。”那么它的症状是什么？
Well, if somebody lose their job, I call them depressed. No, no, no, that's environment. Do you see what I'm saying is that if you looked at the data directly, it would have given diagnoses to you, but they didn't start with symptoms. They started with diagnoses that had just already been around and then assumed these things must have symptoms because we've been talking about them.
好吧，如果有人丢了工作，我称他们为抑郁。不，不，不，那是环境。你明白我的意思吗？如果你直接看数据，它会给你诊断，但他们不是从症状开始的。他们从已经存在的诊断开始，然后假设这些东西一定有症状，因为我们一直在谈论它们。
So we have a different perspective looking at this history than these guys would have thought. So, you know, this approach has a name, though. It's called the approach that I'm describing of looking at the symptoms and then letting them tell you what the diagnoses are. That's literally what factor analysis is. That's what the high top model does for mental health today. And if Spitzer had done it that way, the DSM would look totally different. Like you could never have said, hey, when you come in, what are the biggest symptoms that your patients have?
所以我们看待这段历史的视角与这些人所想的不同。所以，你知道，这种方法有一个名字。它被称为我所描述的观察症状然后让它们告诉你诊断是什么的方法。这实际上就是因子分析。这就是今天心理健康的高层（HiTOP）模型所做的。如果斯皮策那样做，DSM看起来会完全不同。你永远不可能说：“嘿，当你进来时，你的病人最大的症状是什么？”
Okay, here's 50 symptoms. Well, which are the ones that you see in, what are like the ones that you see? this guy who has no eating, he doesn't eat. What are other symptoms do you see at the same time with him? Oh, he also doesn't sleep. Okay, well, how many you guys have somebody who doesn't eat and doesn't sleep? Yeah, we all have one. I mean, sometimes somebody doesn't eat, but it's for this reason,
“好吧，这里有50个症状。那么你看到的那些是什么？比如你看到的那些是什么？这个家伙没有进食，他不吃东西。你同时在他身上看到的其他症状是什么？哦，他也不睡觉。好吧，你们有多少人有不吃东西也不睡觉的人？是的，我们都有一个。我的意思是，有时有人不吃东西，但这是因为这个原因，
but most of the time they don't eat and they have that symptom. Okay, when somebody doesn't eat and they don't sleep, what other of these symptoms do they have? Well, they're sad, and they also, oh, okay, well, some of these people, they have a negative life event, and then they don't eat and they don't sleep, and they're sad for, like, a week. but then other of these people, there's no reason for it at all,
但大多数时候他们不吃东西，他们有那个症状。好吧，当有人不吃东西也不睡觉时，他们还有哪些症状？好吧，他们很悲伤，而且他们也……哦，好吧，这些人中的一些人，他们有一个负面的生活事件，然后他们不吃东西也不睡觉，他们悲伤了大约一周。但其他人，根本没有任何原因，
and they don't eat and they don't sleep, and they're sad, and it comes out of the blue when something's going well, and then it doesn't go away ever. Okay, well, it looks like, you know, temporary life event depression is different fundamentally
他们不吃东西也不睡觉，他们很悲伤，当事情进展顺利时，它突然出现，然后它就再也没有消失过。好吧，看起来，你知道，暂时性的生活事件抑郁在根本上是不同的
from just an endogenous genetic deep brain depression that's now we have two diagnoses. If you do it that way, the brain will tell you what the diagnoses are, the data will. And dopamine disorders, they would look completely different. Like you would, under high top, they would say,
从仅仅是一种内源性遗传的深层大脑抑郁，现在我们有两个诊断。如果你那样做，大脑会告诉你诊断是什么，数据会告诉你。多巴胺疾病，它们看起来会完全不同。比如你会，在高层模型下，他们会说：
okay, it looks like you're prone to psychosis. You're having these symptoms, just like the original people were doing in the hospitals. And because you have these symptoms, we think this is probably going to happen. You're probably going through the prodromal phase of schizophrenia or bipolar or something. Or early phase of bipolar.
“好吧，看起来你容易患精神病。你出现了这些症状，就像医院里最初的人一样。因为你有这些症状，我们认为这很可能会发生。你可能正在经历精神分裂症或双相情感障碍的前驱期。”或者双相情感障碍的早期阶段。
Or it doesn't have a prodromal phase. But, you know, the walls between schizophrenia, bipolar disorder, manic depressive, like even OCD, they would have been more squishy. They would have had more overlap if you'd done it that way, because dopamine disorders share a lot of features now. So Spitzer didn't do it that way, but why? Because that establishment already existed. You couldn't come in and tell these people the language that you've talked in for 50 years.
或者它没有前驱期。但是，你知道，精神分裂症、双相情感障碍、躁郁症，甚至强迫症之间的墙，它们会更模糊。如果那样做，它们会有更多的重叠，因为多巴胺疾病现在有很多共同特征。所以斯皮策没有那样做，但为什么呢？因为那个建制派已经存在了。你不能进来告诉这些人，你们谈论了50年的语言。
Don't talk in it anymore because it's wrong. Depression doesn't exist. Anxiety doesn't exist. Neurosis doesn't exist. Schizophrenia doesn't exist. So let's figure out every single disorder that exists. And then we'll publish a book and tell all the psychiatrists in the world. They build their careers around those categories.
不要再谈论它了，因为它是错的。抑郁症不存在。焦虑症不存在。神经症不存在。精神分裂症不存在。所以让我们找出存在的每一个疾病。然后我们将出版一本书，告诉全世界所有的精神科医生。他们围绕这些类别建立了他们的职业生涯。
Their books were called Blankety Blank of Neurosis, Depression and Anxiety because of blah, blah, blah, blah. You know, what is schizophrenia? They're, their whole, you couldn't tell them that those words don't exist anymore because to them those words were real, even though the data didn't support those words. So he worked backwards. He started with the diagnosis, and then he built the symptom clusters around them. And so if it done it the right way, starting with symptoms and then letting them cluster naturally, the political complications would have been enormous. imagine a room full of psychiatrists with a patient asking, what would you diagnose this person's with?
他们的书被称为《神经症、抑郁和焦虑的某某》，因为等等等等。你知道，什么是精神分裂症？他们的整个……你不能告诉他们这些词不再存在了，因为对他们来说这些词是真实的，尽管数据并不支持这些词。所以他倒着工作。他从诊断开始，然后围绕它们建立了症状群。如果以正确的方式完成，从症状开始，然后让它们自然聚类，政治上的复杂性将是巨大的。想象一个房间里坐满了精神科医生，面对一个病人，问：“你会诊断这个人患有什么？”
And then if they agreed, and they inevitably would, it would expose the unreliability of the whole system. It would be this other Rosenhand experiment, showing that doctors couldn't agree on how these symptoms were supposed to be clustered together, which would have been more of an insult. But if you instead asked for patients, you have already diagnosed with depression,
然后如果他们同意，他们不可避免地会同意，这会暴露整个系统的不可靠性。这将是另一个罗森汉实验（Rosenhan experiment），表明医生无法就这些症状应该如何聚类达成一致，这将是一种更大的侮辱。但如果你转而询问病人，你已经诊断出患有抑郁症，
what symptoms do you see, then you could get agreement, because you could get them to decide how long, how much, how deep, and what does depression look like? but the doctors weren't being tested. They were being consulted. And their expertise was being respected, not challenged.
你看到了什么症状，那么你就能达成一致，因为你可以让他们决定持续多久、多少、多深，抑郁症看起来是什么样的？但医生们并没有被测试。他们是在被咨询。他们的专业知识受到了尊重，而不是挑战。
And this is why typewriter parties worked. One psychiatrist would say, depression lasts for two weeks. And another might say, no, it could just be dysregulation. It has to be four. And Spitzer would sit down and he'd make them compromise. And he literally would lock the door and say, you're not getting out of here until you all tell me how long this is.
这就是“打字机派对”有效的原因。一位精神科医生会说：“抑郁症持续两周。”另一位可能会说：“不，它可能只是失调。必须是四周。”斯皮策会坐下来，让他们妥协。他真的会锁上门说：“你们不告诉我这是多久，就别想从这里出去。”
I don't know. I don't do it. You tell me. And then these guys had to fight and go, okay, fine, three weeks and then leave. And this was politics. Again, it wasn't science. but it produced reliability in that they agreed with each other when they wrote the book, but not necessarily reliability when you use the book outside the room.
“我不知道。我不做这个。你告诉我。”然后这些人不得不争吵，然后说：“好吧，好吧，三周，然后离开。”这就是政治。再说一次，这不是科学。但它产生了可靠性，因为他们在写书时彼此同意，但在房间外使用这本书时，并不一定可靠。
And so here's the crucial point. Checklists aren't inherently bad. They can be a scientifically valid tool, but they have to work forward, not backward. A forward checklist starts with observations. You observe hundreds of thousands of patients. You record every symptom you see. You use statistics to find patterns, which symptoms tend to appear together, which predict certain outcomes, which respond to certain treatments.
所以这是关键点。检查清单本身并不坏。它们可以成为一种科学有效的工具，但它们必须向前工作，而不是向后。向前的检查清单从观察开始。你观察成千上万的病人。你记录你看到的每一个症状。你使用统计数据来寻找模式，哪些症状倾向于一起出现，哪些预测某些结果，哪些对某些治疗有反应。
And then you define your categories based on what you find. But a backwards checklist starts with the categories you already believe in, and then it defines them however you can get people to agree. And this is what Spitzer did. That's not discovery. That's just codification of existing prejudice. You're just taking your bias and then saying, what can we do to the data to kind of assume that what we're thinking is already right. And so when Spitzer was having as typewriter parties,
然后你根据你发现的东西定义你的类别。但向后的检查清单从你已经相信的类别开始，然后尽可能地定义它们，直到人们达成一致。这就是斯皮策所做的。那不是发现。那只是对现有偏见的编纂。你只是带着你的偏见，然后说，我们能对数据做什么来假设我们所想的已经是正确的。所以当斯皮策举行他的打字机派对时，
there's this quieter revolution happening in the basement of American medicine. basement of American medicine. And the revolution wasn't about philosophy or diagnosis. It was about money. Unlike the DSM, which was public and controversial, this revolution happened in a room that nobody knew existed. It's called the RUC or the AMA Special Society, Specialty Society Relative Value Scale Update Committee. But because relative value scale is one word, they say Ruck or relative update committee is the acronym. I don't know. If you've never heard of it, that's by design. It's a private committee
在美国医学的地下室里发生着一场更安静的革命。美国医学的地下室。这场革命不是关于哲学或诊断的。它是关于钱的。与公开且有争议的DSM不同，这场革命发生在一个没人知道存在的房间里。它被称为RUC或AMA专业协会相对价值量表更新委员会。但因为相对价值量表是一个词，他们称之为Ruck或相对更新委员会，这是缩写。我不知道。如果你从未听说过它，那是故意的。这是一个私人委员会，
and it's run by the AMA and it essentially tells the federal government how much Medicaid should pay for every medical procedure. And because the private insurance companies must universally follow Medicaid's lead and Medicare's lead, this committee effectively sets the price
由AMA运营，它本质上告诉联邦政府医疗补助（Medicaid）应该为每项医疗程序支付多少钱。而且因为私人保险公司必须普遍遵循医疗补助和医疗保险（Medicare）的领导，这个委员会实际上设定了价格
for health care in America. If therapists did that, it would be illegal. But the RUC is just advising. They're not a cartel getting all the doctors together. They're just getting the doctors to kind of say what they're. think it should be and Medicaid's going to accept that 90% of the time. So the RUC is exempt from laws that would normally prevent you from doing that. You can't
美国的医疗保健。如果治疗师那样做，那将是非法的。但RUC只是在提供建议。他们不是一个把所有医生聚集在一起的卡特尔。他们只是让医生们说出他们认为应该是什么，而医疗补助90%的时间会接受这一点。所以RUC豁免于通常会阻止你这样做的法律。你不能
really do that in any other kind of profession. Like if you sell bread and then you go to all the other bakers and you say we're charging $2 for bread but we're the only people who sell it in Birmingham. So why don't we charge $50 for bread? The Sherman Trust Act could be used against you. You could be accused of operating a cartel. The way that the RUC advises, it's not really part of it. It's just all the doctors getting together and then telling Medicaid this is what we think, and then Medicaid doing it 90% of the time and then insurance making that mandatory. But that's a thing that is popping up that is related to the way that the DSM is used
真的在任何其他职业中这样做。比如如果你卖面包，然后你去找所有其他面包师，你说我们在伯明翰卖面包收费2美元，但我们是唯一卖面包的人。所以我们为什么不收50美元呢？谢尔曼反托拉斯法（Sherman Trust Act）可以用来对付你。你可能会被指控经营卡特尔。RUC提供建议的方式，它并不是其中的一部分。这只是所有医生聚在一起，然后告诉医疗补助这是我们的想法，然后医疗补助90%的时间照做，然后保险公司使其成为强制性的。但这是一件正在出现的事情，它与DSM的使用方式有关，
and why it gets to be viewed as a Bible and not really what it was intended as, which was just sort of trying to consolidate all of the statistics around diagnosis, that everybody was doing so that we sort of know what's changing and what's not. And so, you know, the RUC is dominated by these specialists. And so their bias is structural and it's overwhelming. They value doing things to people, cutting them, scanning them, injecting them. A lot of times that costs, that has all this equipment, that there's this huge cost associated with, diamond knives and lasers and, you know, x-rays.
以及为什么它被视为圣经，而不是它原本的意图，即只是试图整合围绕诊断的所有统计数据，每个人都在做这些，这样我们就能知道什么是变化的，什么不是。所以，你知道，RUC由这些专家主导。所以他们的偏见是结构性的，而且是压倒性的。他们重视对人做事情，切割他们，扫描他们，注射他们。很多时候，这需要所有这些设备，有巨大的成本，钻石刀、激光和，你知道，X光。
And so we're going to say that that labor is more valuable because it has all this specialty stuff. that cost is associated with. Because they're saying, well, yeah, putting a band-aid on your knee by a doctor, shouldn't cost the same as heart surgery. So how do we set this? And that's what the RUC's job was, was to tell Medicaid, hey, we're all the doctors. We're not lying to you. We're just going to kind of tell you what we think this is worth this year.
所以我们要说这种劳动更有价值，因为它有所有这些专业的东西，成本与之相关。因为他们说：“好吧，是的，医生在你的膝盖上贴创可贴，不应该和心脏手术花费一样多。那么我们如何设定这个？”这就是RUC的工作，告诉医疗补助：“嘿，我们是所有的医生。我们没有对你撒谎。我们只是要告诉你我们认为今年这值多少钱。”
Cancer treatment just got more expensive because you have to buy this new kind of chemo and it costs a whole lot. And so if we do one session of chemo of this type, we think that the payment rate should go up now because the new best practice is to do it a way that it's more expensive. So remember, too, that this was a point where schizophrenia was vanishing and people are being given antipsychotics. So being able to prescribe medication in a time where American medicine is becoming service-based, not relationship-based, service-based. There's not a lot of services that psychiatrists can do other than talk. Because there's not a lot of services they can do, they make the one that they can do really expensive.
癌症治疗刚刚变得更贵，因为你必须购买这种新型化疗，而且成本很高。所以如果我们做一次这种类型的化疗，我们认为支付率现在应该提高，因为新的最佳实践是以更昂贵的方式进行。所以也要记住，这是一个精神分裂症正在消失，人们被给予抗精神病药物的时刻。因此，在美国医学正变得以服务为基础，而不是以关系为基础的时代，能够开出药物。精神科医生除了谈话之外，没有太多服务可以做。因为他们能做的服务不多，他们就让他们能做的那个变得非常昂贵。
And they start to downplay the value of talk therapy. because that's something that all these other professions can do that aren't doctors. So it's the moment when it becomes impossible to pay your med school loan back, just doing talk therapy. And that happens relatively quickly at the same time, that all of these other things that we talked about in the first episode and all of those things about schizophrenia and the backlash to mental health and the crisis of confidence in any of these things to be real is taking place.
他们开始淡化谈话疗法的价值。因为那是所有其他不是医生的职业都能做的事情。所以这是当你仅仅通过谈话疗法就不可能还清医学院贷款的时刻。这种情况发生得相对较快，同时，我们在第一集中谈到的所有其他事情，以及关于精神分裂症的所有事情，对心理健康的强烈反对，以及对任何这些东西是真实的信心危机，都在发生。
And so prescribing medicine sort of becomes the thing that they double down on. All of these things happen, you know, in between the three and the four, the DSM three and the four. And they change American medicine quite a bit. Alan Francis, who chairs the DSM4, he explicitly does not want to be Spitzer. He's like Spitzer created too many of these diagnostic categories. He created too much. We want to get rid of axes. We want to get rid of all of these categories because it needs to be simpler.
所以开药某种程度上成为了他们加倍投入的事情。所有这些事情，你知道，发生在第三版和第四版之间，DSM-3和DSM-4。它们相当大地改变了美国医学。艾伦·弗朗西斯（Alan Francis），DSM-4的主席，他明确不想成为斯皮策。他说斯皮策创造了太多的诊断类别。他创造了太多。我们想要摆脱轴，我们想要摆脱所有这些类别，因为它需要更简单。
And when you make less, then you have to broaden the definitions, or else you're telling somebody who used to be mentally ill and have a diagnosis, you're not mentally ill anymore. Because if you've got fewer categories, they've got to be bigger. So he thinks that to try and get rid of this, this explosion in too many diagnostic categories, that what you should do is just make a couple. But what that does is it means that you broaden the gates so much
当你制造得更少时，你就必须拓宽定义，否则你就是在告诉一个曾经患有精神疾病并有诊断的人，你不再患有精神疾病了。因为如果你有更少的类别，它们就必须更大。所以他认为，为了试图摆脱这种诊断类别过多的爆炸式增长，你应该做的就是只做几个。但这样做意味着你拓宽了大门，以至于
that now everybody has ADHD. everybody has bipolar, everybody has autism, because you're putting so many people in those categories by broadening the definition that now anyone can go in and get diagnosed with it. And so Francis spends the rest of his life basically apologizing for the ADHD and bipolar disorder epidemic, and he says, my opinion's changed.
现在每个人都有多动症，每个人都有双相情感障碍，每个人都有自闭症，因为你通过拓宽定义把这么多人放进了这些类别，现在任何人都可以进去并被诊断出来。所以弗朗西斯余生基本上都在为多动症和双相情感障碍的流行道歉，他说：“我的观点变了。”
I think that any change in the manual that can be misused will be misused. So he expresses tons of regret about the DSM4. he thinks that it pathologized normal behavior. He particularly does not like the ADHD epidemic that gets, you know, every kid in the 90s just gets, I got put on Adderall because I don't even know what I did. I didn't talk, so it wasn't that. I didn't run around, so it wasn't that.
“我认为手册中任何可能被滥用的改变都会被滥用。”所以他表达了大量的遗憾关于DSM-4。他认为它将正常行为病理化了。他特别不喜欢90年代每个孩子都得到的那个多动症流行，我被服用阿得拉（Adderall），因为我甚至不知道我做了什么。我没有说话，所以不是那个。我没有到处跑，所以不是那个。
I got on Adderall, and I still don't know. I saw a psychiatrist in 20 minutes, maybe, probably more like 15, and he asked me if I wet the bed and if I wanted a sucker, and then I got put on a horse dose of Adderall for the next three years of my life. And that is sort of a result of the changes that Francis makes. So like the Asperger's diagnosis in the DSM4 expands autism more to say people who have social impairment, not, you know, direct functional impairment now can be considered kind of autistic. But it still keeps those pretty separate.
我服用了阿得拉，我仍然不知道。我看了精神科医生，可能20分钟，可能更像是15分钟，他问我是否尿床，是否想要一颗糖，然后我在接下来的三年里被服用了大剂量的阿得拉。这就是弗朗西斯所做改变的结果。所以像DSM-4中的阿斯伯格综合征诊断将自闭症扩大到说有社交障碍的人，而不是，你知道，直接功能障碍的人现在可以被认为是某种自闭症。但它仍然保持这些相当独立。
like you either have Asperger's or you have autism, which seems silly because there's quite a, it's a spectrum. And so, so you have to realize that, one, the society's ability to recognize these things trickles out of this book. So when you hear people say something like,
就像你要么有阿斯伯格综合征，要么有自闭症，这看起来很傻，因为有一个相当大的，它是一个谱系。所以，所以你必须意识到，第一，社会识别这些东西的能力是从这本书中流出来的。所以当你听到人们说类似的话时，
oh, well, everybody has autism now, so there must be poison in the water or whatever. Well, there probably is poison in your water. But I don't, you have to look at the change
“哦，好吧，现在每个人都有自闭症，所以水里一定有毒，或者其他什么。”好吧，你的水里可能确实有毒。但我不知道，你必须看看
in the DSM, which said one in basically 2,500 people had autism to the 1980s where you're saying one in 36 people are on the autism spectrum somewhere. And that's a huge change. So yes, a lot more people are autistic or diagnosed as autistic, but it's not because all of a sudden people start getting more autistic really quickly. It's because the diagnosis changed for some reason, whenever people are pointing out autism rates. I'm not talking about researchers. I'm talking about social media.
DSM的变化，它说1980年代大约2500人中有一人患有自闭症，而现在你说36人中有一人在自闭症谱系上的某个地方。这是一个巨大的变化。所以是的，更多的人是自闭症患者或被诊断为自闭症，但这并不是因为人们突然很快变得更自闭了。这是因为诊断由于某种原因改变了，每当人们指出自闭症率时。我不是在谈论研究人员。我是在谈论社交媒体。
They forget that the three and the four were different books. And the four TR was a different book. And so that's why this fight is sort of happening now around the five even with autism, where you have people that are like, we should look at this star model where it's not a spectrum left right. It's a spectrum like, where is the impairment? Is it an interpersonal functioning? Is it in special interest?
他们忘记了第三版和第四版是不同的书。第四版TR是一本不同的书。所以这就是为什么这场争斗现在在第五版周围发生，即使是自闭症，你有像这样的人，我们应该看看这个星形模型，它不是一个左右谱系。它是一个像这样的谱系，障碍在哪里？是在人际交往功能中吗？是在特殊兴趣中吗？
Is it in the ability to read emotions? Is it the ability to regulate sensory things? Those are pretty different. You know, I like the star model a lot, but one of the things I've pointed out about it is when you're doing that, you're putting even more people than one in 36 people potentially in the category of having autism. So at that point, what's neuronormal, what's neurotypical, what's neurodivergent, maybe you're just, maybe psychology is defying those categories at you and you are still struggling to try and
是在阅读情绪的能力中吗？是调节感官事物的能力吗？那些是非常不同的。你知道，我非常喜欢星形模型，但我指出的关于它的一件事是，当你这样做时，你把比36人中1人更多的人潜在地放进了患有自闭症的类别中。所以在那一点上，什么是神经正常，什么是神经典型，什么是神经多样性，也许你只是，也许心理学正在用这些类别来定义你，而你仍然在努力尝试
categorize them. So Francis learns this bitter lesson. Bureaucratic methodologies are inherently inflammatory, and once a checklist exists, the pressures from patients wanting validation or enabling in the worst case. And parents that are seeking help or in the worst case to control their children will pressure pharmaceutical companies to pressure doctors to get this thing and pharmaceutical companies are rushing to fill the void. Look how fast you go from Adderall alone, which is basically a World War II drug, to, you know,
对它们进行分类。所以弗朗西斯吸取了这个痛苦的教训。官僚方法本质上是煽动性的，一旦检查清单存在，来自寻求验证的病人的压力，或者在最坏的情况下是赋能。而寻求帮助的父母，或者在最坏的情况下是控制他们的孩子，将向制药公司施压，向医生施压以获得这个东西，而制药公司正急于填补这个空白。看看你从阿得拉（Adderall）本身，它基本上是一种二战药物，到，你知道，
just hundreds and hundreds of these things that are getting patented all the time. and they still are. I mean, there's still new non-generic forms of Adderall. And like an oral, a lot of those stimulants are so weird because it really is the same drug. Like it's, it's really just kind of like the base is just that meth. But the salt and everything that you bind it with does change the way that you feel it a lot. Like a lot of those new drugs, patients report feeling completely different. And this is the one that works, the patients that have ADHD and need it. And they can't afford it. So it's they're not, it's not, it's not, totally different, but there's a huge, they're not all totally the same. I'm not making that case,
仅仅是数百种一直被申请专利的东西，速度有多快。而且它们仍然是。我的意思是，仍然有新的非仿制药形式的阿得拉。而且像口服，很多那些兴奋剂非常奇怪，因为它们确实是同一种药。就像它，它真的只是有点像基础就是那种冰毒。但你用来结合它的盐和所有东西确实改变了你感受它的方式。就像很多那些新药，病人报告感觉完全不同。这是对患有多动症并需要它的病人有效的那个。而且他们负担不起。所以它不是，它不是，它不是，完全不同，但有一个巨大的，它们并不全是完全一样的。我不是在提出那个案例，
but there's this huge rush to make new patentable drugs. Parents really like it, schools really like it. Francis really regrets it. So when the DSM-5 is starting, and the NIH is already kind of angry because they've watched how they've been promised basically for 30 years that they're about to get the biological root of all this stuff. Schizophrenia has a biological route, so we're going to find the other ones. We just need more drugs. Once the drugs are discovered, then they'll treat the disorder, and then that proves that the disorder is real. It's been 30 years that DSM4 has zero biological basis and a lot of the changes that it makes. The scientists are frustrated with the psychologists, and when they see that they're chairing the panels of the five with these huge, huge, huge committees that are basically listening to people's views on the politics, but the structure, the actual change is these people that basically wrote the DSM4, which the NIH didn't like.
但有一种制造新的可专利药物的巨大冲动。父母真的很喜欢它，学校真的很喜欢它。弗朗西斯真的很后悔。所以当DSM-5开始时，NIH已经有点生气了，因为他们看着他们基本上被承诺了30年，他们即将得到所有这些东西的生物学根源。精神分裂症有生物学根源，所以我们要找到其他的。我们只需要更多的药物。一旦发现了药物，那么它们就会治疗这种疾病，然后这证明了这种疾病是真实的。DSM-4已经30年了，它没有任何生物学基础，它所做的很多改变。科学家们对心理学家感到沮丧，当他们看到他们正在用这些庞大、庞大、庞大的委员会主持第五版的专家组时，这些委员会基本上是在听取人们对政治的看法，但结构，实际的改变是这些人基本上写了DSM-4，而NIH不喜欢它。
They do this thing that's pretty wild, which is before the DSM-5 even comes out, two weeks before it's published after the committee's over. They say, yeah, we haven't read the book yet, but it's garbage and we're not going to use it. And no longer can any of this be used for research. And I think probably if Thomas Ensel wasn't director of the NIH at that point, like if he wasn't the director of the National Institute of Mental Health, I said NIH. I'm sorry, NIMH. But one part of it. But like, if he wasn't over that, that anyone else probably would have done that anyway. Like this tension had been building for a long time.
他们做了一件相当疯狂的事，就是在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》第五版（DSM-5）发布之前，在委员会工作结束后、正式出版前的两周，他们就说：“是的，我们还没读过这本书，但它是垃圾，我们不会使用它。”从此，这些内容再也不能用于研究了。我想，如果当时托马斯·因塞尔（Thomas Insel）不是美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）的负责人——我是说，如果他不是美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH）的所长，我刚才说成NIH了，抱歉，是NIMH——如果不是他掌管这一切，换作别人可能也会这么做。这种紧张关系已经积压了很长时间。
And so Encel says, you know, the DSM has been described as a Bible for the field, but it's at best a dictionary and its weakness is that it has no validity. This was extraordinary. The federal government is saying all of American health care funding, because most of that comes from DARPA and from the government, is no longer ever going to use these. And it should have been bigger news because for three decades, You know, the NIMH had forced researchers to use these DSM categories.
于是因塞尔说，你知道，DSM一直被描述为该领域的“圣经”，但充其量它只是一本字典，其弱点在于它毫无效度。这太非同寻常了。联邦政府在说，所有美国医疗保健资金——因为大部分资金来自国防高级研究计划局（DARPA）和政府——将不再使用这些分类。这本应成为更大的新闻，因为三十年来，NIMH一直强迫研究人员使用这些DSM分类。
If you wanted to grant a study on depression, if you wanted to get a grant and study depression, you had to study DSM depression. Patients who met the specific checklist criteria. But if you wanted to study schizophrenia, you had to study DSM schizophrenia. And Insull realized that this was sabotaging research, and he called it a bucket of sludge. He said that you were just throwing these things into these buckets, but that the buckets didn't really tell you anything. They were useless. You know, if you're trying to cure a fever and you gather a thousand patients who all have elevated body temperature, some of them have the flu,
如果你想获得研究抑郁症的资助，你就必须研究DSM定义的抑郁症，即那些符合特定检查清单标准的患者。如果你想研究精神分裂症，就必须研究DSM定义的精神分裂症。因塞尔意识到这正在破坏研究，他称之为“一桶污泥”。他说，你只是把这些东西扔进桶里，但桶本身并不能告诉你任何信息。它们毫无用处。你知道，如果你想治愈发烧，你召集了一千名体温升高的患者，其中一些人得了流感，
some have cancer, some have heat stroke, some have autoimmune disorders, some have, you know, just a fever from a cold. And you run all of the drug trials through them, you don't really find out which one cures the common cold. You don't really find out which one cures the flu. You don't really find out which one cures cancer because you put all the people that had elevated temperature in one room and assumed that the route was the same, which has been an accusation that the APA was doing that with the DSM for a long time. You're just putting all this stuff together, but that doesn't really tell you anything. And so the trials fail, you know, and the DSM task force had promised the NIH something revolutionary. They said, give us money in time and we'll find these
一些人得了癌症，一些人中暑了，一些人患有自身免疫性疾病，还有一些人只是因为感冒而发烧。如果你对他们进行所有的药物试验，你并不能真正找出哪种药能治愈普通感冒，不能找出哪种能治愈流感，也不能找出哪种能治愈癌症，因为你把所有体温升高的人都关在一个房间里，并假设他们的病因是一样的。长期以来，美国精神医学学会（APA）一直被指责在DSM中这样做。你只是把所有东西混在一起，但这并不能告诉你任何实质内容。所以试验失败了，你知道，DSM工作组曾向NIH承诺了一些革命性的东西。他们说，给我们钱和时间，我们会找到这些
biomarkers, these brain scans, and we'll prove the disorders are real. They spend 14 years. They spend $25 million, and then they fail. And they basically had made that promise 30 years ago. The DSM-5 comes out. It still just shows lists of symptoms. There's not really any kind of theoretical change. There's still no neurobiological marker for condition or test. And the science has plenty of data.
生物标志物，这些脑部扫描，我们会证明这些疾病是真实存在的。他们花了14年，花了2500万美元，结果却失败了。他们基本上在30年前就做出了那个承诺。DSM-5发布了，它依然只是症状列表。并没有任何理论上的改变。对于任何病症或测试，仍然没有任何神经生物学标志物。而科学界其实有大量的数据。
There were biomarkers for mental health that they could have followed, but they're not following them. Those are kind of inconvenient because we're looking for the biomarkers for the diagnosis. we have, not looking at what the biomarkers are telling us about how these brain conditions actually work. And so the NIMH walks away from the DSM and they say that the research domain criteria, or RDOC, is what they're going to replace it with. But RDOC is not a diagnostic manual.
本有一些心理健康的生物标志物他们本可以追踪，但他们没有。那些标志物有点“不方便”，因为我们是在寻找现有诊断的标志物，而不是观察这些标志物告诉我们大脑状况实际上是如何运作的。因此，NIMH放弃了DSM，并表示将用“研究领域标准”（RDoC）来取代它。但RDoC并不是一本诊断手册。
You can't use it to diagnose a patient. You can't use it to bill insurance. It's a research framework with Rose constructing like fear or working memory or reward responsiveness. and its columns of units of analysis for those traits like genes, molecules, circuits, behavior. It's sort of trying to cross-analyze all of these measurable variables in this giant database. So most of the boxes in that grid are empty. And that's the point.
你不能用它来诊断病人，也不能用它来向保险公司报销。它是一个研究框架，包含诸如恐惧、工作记忆或奖励反应等结构，以及针对这些特征的分析单位列，如基因、分子、回路、行为。它试图在这个巨大的数据库中交叉分析所有这些可测量的变量。所以那个网格中的大多数方框都是空的。而这正是重点所在。
The NIMH's message to researchers was stop studying depression, start studying the specific brain circuits, the control mood. We don't know what goes in these boxes yet, but your job is to find out. We're telling you what you have to use. You failed. We're taking the keys away. from you we're going to drive the car in this direction and this was intellectually honest and scientifically sound but it left research stranded because essentially they had said ardoc is this massive massive
NIMH给研究人员的信息是：停止研究抑郁症，开始研究控制情绪的具体大脑回路。我们还不知道这些方框里应该填什么，但你们的工作就是去发现。我们告诉你们必须使用什么。你们失败了，我们要收回钥匙。我们要驾驶这辆车朝这个方向前进。这在学术上是诚实的，在科学上是合理的，但它让研究陷入了困境，因为本质上他们说RDoC是一个极其庞大的
massive massive project it's basically a database to cross-reference all of the variables that we have and it'll probably be wet ready in like 10 to 20 years and then the thing that was supposed to take two decades to make they force everybody to use because they think so lowly of the dsm 5 And it's worth noting that, you know, the NIMH itself said that Ardok wasn't ready. They said that it wasn't good to go. So you're probably wondering, like I mentioned high top before, that does the thing that Robert Spitzer should have done if it wasn't for all the politics. You know, there's high top and it clusters everything around the P factors and G factors.
极其庞大的项目，它基本上是一个交叉引用我们所有变量的数据库，可能需要10到20年才能准备好。然后，他们强迫所有人使用这个本应需要二十年才能完成的东西，因为他们非常看不起DSM-5。值得注意的是，NIMH自己也说RDoC还没准备好。他们说它还没到可以使用的地步。所以你可能在想，就像我之前提到的HiTOP，它做了罗伯特·斯皮策（Robert Spitzer）本该做但因政治原因没做成的事。你知道，有HiTOP，它围绕P因子和G因子将一切进行聚类。
It looks for, it basically, without re-explaining high top, it looks for you know comorbidity like a puzzle and it finds you know where symptoms are actually clustering so why didn't that in iMH and thomas insul why didn't he say i'm going to use
它寻找……基本上，在不重新解释HiTOP的情况下，它寻找共病，就像拼图一样，它发现症状实际上是在哪里聚类的。那么为什么NIMH和托马斯·因塞尔没有说“我要使用
uh high top instead of ardoc r doc's not going to be ready for 20 years it's not designed to do this anyway um high top is you don't like the direction the dsm is going high top gives you all of the empirically derived data that you need it's already being seen in psychics research for certain things as this gold standard. So why not use that? It solves your
HiTOP而不是RDoC”呢？RDoC还要20年才能准备好，而且它本来就不是为了这个设计的。嗯，HiTOP是……如果你不喜欢DSM的发展方向，HiTOP为你提供了所有你需要的经验数据。在某些心理学研究中，它已经被视为黄金标准。那么为什么不使用它呢？它解决了你的
comorbidity problem. It maps better onto what we already know about genes and circuits and how they're basically competing networks, not like one thing that you can find like a brain tumor and cut out and then your depression is cured. But Hightop still has the same fundamental flaw as the DSM. It's based on symptoms. And it tells you which symptoms cluster together, but it doesn't tell you why. It doesn't give you biomarkers. It's still looking at how people feel. and not what's in their brain. And so I don't really like what the NIMH does. Two things can both be the wrong direction, right?
共病问题。它能更好地映射到我们已经了解的基因和回路，以及它们如何基本上是竞争网络，而不是像你可以找到并切除的脑肿瘤那样，切除后抑郁症就治愈了。但HiTOP仍然有与DSM相同的根本缺陷。它是基于症状的。它告诉你哪些症状聚在一起，但它不告诉你原因。它不提供生物标志物。它仍然是在观察人们的感受，而不是观察他们大脑里发生了什么。所以我并不真的喜欢NIMH的做法。两件事可能都是错误的方向，对吧？
Because Insul and the NIMH, they wanted to skip symptoms entirely and go to biology so they didn't have to listen to how people felt ever again. And they didn't want a better map of how people describe their suffering. They wanted a map of what's happening in the brain. And so Ardoch was their attempt to build that biological foundation from scratch too early because they didn't like the direction that the DSM5 went in so much, even before it came out. But the irony is that Ardok might never have been clinically useful.
因为因塞尔和NIMH想完全跳过症状，直接进入生物学，这样他们就再也不用听人们的感受了。他们不想要一张关于人们如何描述痛苦的更好地图，他们想要一张大脑中正在发生什么的地图。所以RDoC是他们试图从零开始建立生物学基础的尝试，而且太早了，因为他们太不喜欢DSM-5的发展方向了，甚至在它发布之前就不喜欢。但讽刺的是，RDoC可能永远不会有临床用途。
It might never be. It's been over a decade since Ensel's announcement, and we still can't diagnose anyone using brain circuits. But meanwhile, Hightop offers a genuinely superior symptom-based system that could be implemented tomorrow, but nobody's implementing it. But the thing is, with Hightop, you could examine genuine longitudinal data, how much the these conditions are genetic, how much is learned, how much is environmental, we could finally start to untangle the nature versus nurture knot that's made psychiatric research so frustrating. What is what and where do they intersect? But part of nature versus nurture will always remain this mystery because science can only see so
它可能永远不会有。距离因塞尔的宣布已经过去十多年了，我们仍然无法使用大脑回路来诊断任何人。但与此同时，HiTOP提供了一个在明天就可以实施的、真正优越的基于症状的系统，但没有人去实施它。但问题是，有了HiTOP，你可以检查真实的纵向数据：这些疾病有多少是遗传的，有多少是后天习得的，有多少是环境因素造成的。我们终于可以开始解开那个让精神病学研究如此令人沮丧的“先天与后天”之结。什么是先天，什么是后天，它们在哪里交汇？但先天与后天的一部分将永远是一个谜，因为科学只能看到
far into the deep brain where things are happening in split seconds. And that's just the reality of a complex system like that. Probably one of the most complex system that exists. But one of the deepest problems with current diagnoses is that they point at something that's almost always both, a predisposition nature and an environmental trigger, nurture, that sit on top of each other. And here's the kicker, the genetic predisposition,
大脑深处发生的事情，那些在几分之一秒内发生的事情。这就是像这样复杂系统的现实。这可能是现存最复杂的系统之一。但当前诊断最深层的问题之一是，它们指向的东西几乎总是两者兼有：一种先天倾向和一种后天环境触发因素，它们叠加在一起。最关键的是，遗传倾向
and the environmental trigger are found in the same environment because families share both genes and environment. And a child inherits their parents' neurobiology and then has those parents as parents. So trying to separate these things with something like Ardok is probably impossible. And if it ever gets any kind of consensus, it's going to be very reductive. So there's a famous case that illustrates this complexity.
和环境触发因素是在同一个环境中被发现的，因为家庭共享基因和环境。孩子继承了父母的神经生物学，然后又由这些父母抚养。所以试图用RDoC之类的东西把这些分开可能是不可能的。如果它真的达成了某种共识，那也将是非常还原论的。所以有一个著名的案例说明了这种复杂性。
Carl Jung treated Lucia Joyce, which is the daughter of James Joyce, the writer. And in the 30s, Jung treated Lucia for what was called schizophrenia. And she was the daughter of, I mean, Joyce wrote Ulysses in Fenningens Wake. You know, he was one of the biggest writers in the world. And he was this modernist that was throwing everything out and going into these kind of wild landscapes that classical literature didn't do and that were very modern and chaotic and explorations of stream of consciousness
卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）治疗过露西娅·乔伊斯（Lucia Joyce），她是作家詹姆斯·乔伊斯（James Joyce）的女儿。在30年代，荣格治疗露西娅所谓的“精神分裂症”。她是……我的意思是，乔伊斯写了《尤利西斯》和《芬尼根的守灵夜》。你知道，他是世界上最伟大的作家之一。他是一位现代主义者，他抛弃了一切，进入了古典文学所没有的那种狂野景观，那些非常现代、混乱且对意识流的探索，
and dream logic, linguistic fragmentation. And Jung saw, you know, the genes in Joyce, but that he could go to this place and he could return, but that the daughter couldn't. She was just drowning. And Joyce, you know, could access the unconscious voluntarily for his art and then he could return. But Lucia was pulled into this under involuntary place that she couldn't find her way back to reality from.
以及梦境逻辑、语言碎片化。荣格看到，你知道，乔伊斯身上有这些基因，但他可以进入那个地方，然后回来，但他的女儿却不能。她只是在溺水。乔伊斯可以为了艺术自愿进入潜意识，然后回来。但露西娅被拉进了一个非自愿的地方，她无法从中找到回到现实的路。
And this image of a diver versus the drowning person became one of the most powerful ways that Jungian conceptualization entered non-Yungian audiences. Because Joseph Campbell at the same time, the mythographer, is writing about schizophrenia and mythology and the unconscious and their effect on our life. This is this unseen world that's affecting this. It's the way we tell stories. It's the way we make meaning. It's the keys to our soul. And so Jung's interpretation was that Joyce, as this untethered modernist and bohemian, had never taught his daughter how to handle the unconscious.
这种“潜水者”与“溺水者”的意象，成为了荣格概念进入非荣格受众的最有力方式之一。因为约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell）——那位神话学家——当时也在写关于精神分裂症、神话、潜意识以及它们对我们生活的影响。这是一个正在影响我们的隐形世界。这是我们讲述故事的方式，是我们创造意义的方式，是通往我们灵魂的钥匙。所以荣格的解释是，乔伊斯作为一个不受束缚的现代主义者和波希米亚人，从未教过他的女儿如何处理潜意识。
And so Joyce retreated into those depths of the unconscious on a whim for his work, but he had the capacity to return, and his daughter lacked that capacity. And Jung was probably sensing subjectively that part of Lucia's condition was hereditary, that she may have shared some of her father's unusual relationship to primary process thinking. And that part was environmental. Her father's inability to structure his own life and really be a father, even though he's very close with her, he was very, you know, kind of wild guy, didn't give her this model of psychological groundedness.
所以乔伊斯可以随心所欲地退回到潜意识的深处进行创作，但他有能力回来，而他的女儿缺乏这种能力。荣格可能主观地感觉到露西娅病情的一部分是遗传的，她可能分享了她父亲与原始过程思维之间的一些不寻常的关系。而那部分是环境因素。她父亲无法构建自己的生活，无法真正成为一个父亲，尽管他与她很亲近，但他是一个非常……你知道，有点狂野的人，没有给她提供这种心理基础的模型。
And so he blamed Joyce, Jung did, and said, you know, the unlived life of the parent is the biggest force in the child's life. All this stuff that you haven't reckoned with in your olden life as a father is now eating your child. Now, we know now the genetic genes there. some of this maybe would have happened. Jung is feeling it. Some of it probably comes from James Joyce's inability to be a father that can provide order and be what this kid needs.
所以他责怪乔伊斯，荣格说，你知道，父母未活出的生活是孩子生命中最大的力量。所有你在作为父亲的旧生活中没有解决的事情，现在正在吞噬你的孩子。现在，我们知道基因在那里。其中一些可能无论如何都会发生。荣格感觉到了这一点。其中一些可能来自詹姆斯·乔伊斯无法成为一个能提供秩序并成为这个孩子所需要的父亲。
Some of it, you know, is a genetic capacity that is just endogenous to Lucia and Joyce's genes and they're manifesting in Lucia in this way where she's going to have schizophrenia anyway. But that's the kind of area where High Top could help. if we had dimensional data based on psychosis proneness across generations correlated with family environments and parenting styles and creative professions and substance use, we could start to make their finer judgments about these correlations. We could bring science to the questions that analysis could only address through intuition, and we could understand when the artistic temperament is a gift and when it becomes a vulnerability and what the environmental factors are that tip the balance, if any. And, you know, Theodore Porter, one of the things, one of the
其中一些，你知道，是一种内在于露西娅和乔伊斯基因的遗传能力，它们以这种方式在露西娅身上表现出来，无论如何她都会患上精神分裂症。但这就是HiTOP可以提供帮助的领域。如果我们有基于跨代精神病倾向的维度数据，并将其与家庭环境、教养方式、创造性职业和物质使用相关联，我们就可以开始对这些相关性做出更精细的判断。我们可以将科学引入那些分析只能通过直觉来解决的问题，我们可以理解艺术气质何时是一种天赋，何时又成为一种脆弱性，以及哪些环境因素打破了平衡（如果有的话）。而且，你知道，西奥多·波特（Theodore Porter）说过的一件事是，
of the things he says is that sciences that are softer, like economics, they use numbers more because they're insecure. Psychiatrists don't have the same authority as a heart surgeon at justifying why they made a decision that they made. And so from the beginning, the profession has been looked down upon by these real doctors. So when you lack authority, you reach for mechanical objectivity, and you create checklist and codes and rigorous seeming procedures, not because they reveal truth, but because they protect you from criticism. If someone challenges your diagnosis, you can point to the checklist. I did make this up. I followed the criteria. The DSM is a technology of self-defense, low trust, as Porter would say. And, you know, that genealogy of authority,
比较“软”的科学，比如经济学，它们更多地使用数字，因为它们缺乏安全感。精神科医生在证明他们所做决定的理由时，没有心脏外科医生那样的权威。因此，从一开始，这个职业就被真正的医生所看不起。所以当你缺乏权威时，你就会寻求机械的客观性，你创建检查清单、代码和看似严谨的程序，不是因为它们揭示了真理，而是因为它们保护你免受批评。如果有人质疑你的诊断，你可以指向检查清单。我没有编造，我遵循了标准。正如波特所说，DSM是一种自我防御的低信任技术。而且，你知道，那种权威的谱系，
he talks about. He says when institutions lack confidence in their own foundation, theoretically, they try and ground themselves in something that's beyond question. Churches trace their authority to divine revelation, royal families constructs, constructs, constructs, to genealogies linking them to mythical ancestors. You know, Saddam Hussein famously fabricated this lineage to the prophet Muhammad that it was impossible and to ancient Babylonian kings from, you know, Proto Persia. And psychiatry does the same thing. It has to ground its authority in science and biology, in neuroscience, and genetics.
他谈到了这一点。他说，当机构在理论上对自己基础缺乏信心时，它们会试图将自己建立在某种不容置疑的东西之上。教会将他们的权威追溯到神圣的启示，皇室家族构建……构建……构建……将他们与神话祖先联系起来的谱系。你知道，萨达姆·侯赛因曾著名地伪造了这种与先知穆罕默德的血统，这在当时是不可能的，还有与古代巴比伦国王的血统。精神病学也做了同样的事情。它必须将其权威建立在科学、生物学、神经科学和遗传学之上。
And it imports the prestige of the hard sciences to cover for its own uncertainty. And the checklists are dressed up as operationalized criteria. The symptoms are counted as scientific measure. and the whole apparatus is designed to look more like a hard science than it really is. I think probably the failure of the DSM 3, 4, and 5 are proof that we're never really going to build this objective model that makes all the people disagree unless we change the language quite a bit. But, you know, Nichi had that insight that the claim to authority often reveals this depth of insecurity. And the more desperately you insist that your knowledge is objective and scientific, the more that you are really revealing that you know it's not. A secure discipline doesn't need to constantly prove itself.
它引入了硬科学的声望来掩盖自己的不确定性。检查清单被包装成操作化的标准。症状被算作科学的衡量标准，整个装置被设计成看起来比实际更像一门硬科学。我认为DSM-3、4和5的失败可能证明，除非我们大幅改变语言，否则我们永远无法建立这种让所有人都达成一致的客观模型。但是，你知道，尼采有这样一个洞察力：对权威的宣称往往揭示了这种深层的不安全感。你越是拼命坚持你的知识是客观和科学的，你就越是在揭示你其实知道它并非如此。一个稳固的学科不需要不断地证明自己。
An insecure one is always generating data, publishing studies, adding more criteria to the checklist, you know, checking its assumptions, having bigger fights, trying to prove that this time it's really, truly science is what we've been doing in psychology for a really long time. And I think one of the reasons why that is is that there is this underlying insecurity because we're talking about emotion. So we have to retreat into logic and then pretend that we arrived at it purely by logic. But what really happens is that you're just hiding your own blind spots, your own emotional and subjective assumptions from yourself when you pretend that you're beating this purely objective thing. And here's the deeper issue that neither the DSM nor its critics want to face. you have to start somewhere. Science rests on assumptions that can't be proven
一个不稳固的学科总是在生成数据、发表研究、在检查清单中添加更多标准、检查自己的假设、进行更大的争论，试图证明“这一次真的是科学了”，这就是我们在心理学中长期以来一直在做的事情。我认为原因之一是存在这种潜在的不安全感，因为我们在谈论情绪。所以我们必须退回到逻辑中，然后假装我们纯粹是通过逻辑得出的结论。但真正发生的是，当你假装自己在处理这种纯粹客观的东西时，你只是在向自己隐藏自己的盲点、自己的情感和主观假设。这里有一个DSM及其批评者都不愿面对的更深层的问题：你必须从某处开始。科学建立在无法在科学本身之内被证明的假设之上。
within the science itself. You know, physics assumes that the universe is regular and comprehensible. And biology assumes that living things can be explained mechanistically. And psychology has to assume
你知道，物理学假设宇宙是有规律且可理解的。生物学假设生命体可以用机械论来解释。而心理学必须假设
something about what minds are, what self is, how they work, what health means. And I think that it has to assume that these things are back and forth between a biology and an environment
关于心灵是什么、自我是什么、它们如何运作、健康意味着什么的一些东西。我认为它必须假设这些东西是在生物学和环境之间来回波动的，
and that you're always imperfectly measuring how much is what, a little bit more than we do now. The DSM's problem is not that it makes assumptions. It's that it pretends not to. By claiming to be a theoretical,
而且你总是无法完美地衡量什么是多少，比我们现在做的要多一点。DSM的问题不在于它做出了假设，而在于它假装没有。通过声称是“无理论的”，
by refusing to say why symptoms cluster the way they do, the manual hides its own assumptions and the way that it got to them instead of examining them. So what are those hidden assumptions? That mental disorders are discrete categories rather than continuous dimensions. That's probably wrong. That symptoms can be meaningfully separated
通过拒绝说明症状为何以这种方式聚类，该手册隐藏了自己的假设以及得出这些假设的方式，而不是去审视它们。那么这些隐藏的假设是什么呢？即精神障碍是离散的类别而不是连续的维度。这可能是错的。即症状可以有意义地与产生它们的环境分离开来。这可能是错的。但“信度”（人们是否达成一致）比“效度”（什么是真实的）更重要。也许大多数人在评估病人时只是错了，因为这个职业走上了一条奇怪的道路。即痛苦可以在不被解释的情况下被衡量。这可能是错的。即个体是适当的分析单位，而不是家庭、社区、社会系统、经济系统。这是有争议的。
from the context that produce them. That's probably wrong. But reliability where people agreeing matters more than validity, which is what's true. Maybe most people were just wrong when they assessed the patient because the profession's gone in this weird way. And that suffering can be measured without being interpreted. That's probably wrong. That the individual is the proper unit of analysis rather than the family, the community, the social system, the economic system. That's debatable.
我可能更倾向于后者，而不是DSM所假设的。所以检查清单的一个深刻失败在于它把一切都扁平化了，假装诊断只是诊断，所有的诊断都是一样的。如果它们不在那本书里，它们就不存在；如果它们在，它们就存在，这种二元论。它把它们都当作同一种东西。我不认为当我们谈论诊断时，它们是一样的。如果你有一个分层模型，你可以说，好吧，第一层是相当深层的精神状况。这些东西有从生命早期就存在的生物标志物。它们不会发生根本性的改变。比如严重程度较高的自闭症等智力障碍。你知道，
I'm probably going to lean more towards that one than what the DSM. assumes. So one of the profound failures of the checklist is that it flattens everything to sort of pretend that a diagnosis is just a diagnosis and that all diagnoses are the same. If they're not in this book, they don't exist. And if they are, they do, this binary. It treats them as all the same kind of thing. And I don't really think when we talk about diagnosis that they are at all. If you had a layered model, what you could do is say, okay, layer one is pretty deep. mental conditions. These things have biomarkers that are present from early life. They don't fundamentally change. Intellectual disability like autism at the more severe end. You know,
这些不是来来去去的疾病。它们是大脑结构上的差异。然后第二层是遗传和内源性疾病。那些可能是生物学的、对药物有持续反应的、在家族中遗传的东西。你知道，多巴胺障碍、精神分裂症、双相情感障碍，我们可能没有完全理解其机制，但我们有外部标志物。每次他们服用锂盐，他们就会稳定下来。所以即使我们没有标志物，我们也知道它相关，因为它对药物有持续的反应。每次他们服用抗精神病药物，精神病症状就会缓解。
these aren't diseases that come and go. Their differences in how the brain is structured. And then genetic and endogenous conditions is layer two. Things that are probably biological that respond consistently to medication that run in families. You know, the dopamine disorders, schizophrenia, bipolar, we may not fully understand the mechanism, but we have external markers. And every time they take lithium, they stabilize. So even if we don't have a marker, we kind of know it's related because it responds to the medication consistently. And every time they take antipsychotics, the psychosis remits.
某种生物学上的东西正在发生。你知道，然后是第三层，你说那些曾经是核心精神病学诊断的东西，我们现在称之为抑郁症、焦虑症、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。系统失调了。也许药物有帮助，但通过谈话疗法改变认知或环境可能是最适用的。这不是精神分裂症，这是抑郁症。也许抗抑郁药有帮助，
Something biological is happening. You know, and then you have layer three, and you say things that used to be the core psychiatric diagnosis, we now call depression, anxiety, PTSD. Here's the system is out of whack. Maybe medication helps, but probably changing perception or the environment through talk therapy is the most indicated thing. It's not schizophrenia, it's depression. Like maybe an antidepressant helps,
但你可能还需要重构你的思维才能保持好转。也许是创伤。也许是遗传易感性。也许两者兼有。关键的洞察是，这些疾病通常对非生物学治疗有反应。所以治疗对它们有效。
but you also probably have to restructure your thinking in order to stay better. Maybe it's trauma. Maybe it's genetic vulnerability. Maybe it's both. The key insight is that these conditions often respond to non-biological treatment. So therapy works for them.
你知道，有时它比药物更有效。这种障碍不是一种脑部疾病。它是一种可以改变的失调模式。第四层，性格层面的，那些不是主要基于症状，而是关于个人生活模式的东西，人格障碍、回避、僵化，人们回避改变或回避生活重要部分的地方。这与他们的大脑化学物质无关。
You know, sometimes it works better than medication. The disorder isn't a brain disease. It's a pattern of dysregulation that can be changed. Layer four, characterological, things that aren't primarily symptom base, but are about the person's pattern of living, personality disorders, avoidance, rigidity, places where people deflect from change or they avoid big parts of life. This isn't about their brain chemistry.
这与他们的假设、习惯、习得的反应有关。这些是治疗师每天处理的事情，人格、负面的自我理解和缺乏洞察力。然后是第五层，那些他们不断尝试、特殊利益团体不断游说想要加入书中的东西，人们不想这样做是因为它们太受环境影响了，但它们也与心理健康有关，所以它们可能应该在书中。你知道，比如纠缠的家庭系统、父母疏离、种族主义、贫困、歧视的影响。DSM不想把这些东西变成病理学，因为它们太受环境影响了，
It's about their assumptions, their habits, their learned responses. These are what therapists work with every day, the personality and the negative self-understanding and the lack of insight. And then the layer five, the things that they keep trying, special interest groups, keep trying to lobby to get into the book that people don't want to do it because they're so environmental, but they also relate to mental health, so they probably should be in the book. You know, things like in mesh family systems, parental alienation, effects of racism, poverty, discrimination. The DSM doesn't want to turn those things into a pathology because they're so environmental,
但这些环境变量可能与讨论前四层相关。所以这种分层系统的一个优势是，你可以更快地决定最好的治疗方法。而且，让我们问问心理健康到底是什么。在我们开始试图弄清楚如何处理它之前，先定义它。让我们决定它是什么。你知道，丽贝卡·戈尔茨坦（Rebecca Goldstein）在她最近的一本书中通过这个“重要性地图”提供了关键的洞察。在《心灵-身体问题》中，她说，地图实际上是其居民感知的投射，一个人在地图上的位置是由对他来说什么重要决定的，什么重要得压倒一切。谁是无名小卒，谁是大人物？她最近上了大卫·伊格曼（David Eagleman）的播客，这就是我发现
but those environmental variables probably should be relevant to discussing like the first four layers. So an advantage of that layer system, you know, you can go through and decide what the best treatment is a little bit quicker. You know, and also, let's ask the question what mental health even is. Let's define that one before we start trying to figure out how to do it. Let's decide what it is. You know, Rebecca Goldstein, she offers a crucial insight with this mattering map in one of her recent books. In the mind-body problem, she says, the map, in fact, is a projection of its inhabitants perceptions, a person's location on it is determined by what matters to him matters overwhelmingly. Who are the nobodies and who are the somebodies? She was on David Eagleman's podcast recently, which is how I found
那本书的原因，因为我很喜欢她的谈话。如果你喜欢这类东西，那是另一本好书，而且他绝对比我聪明得多。但她基本上是在说，大脑的工作是在世界上建立秩序。当它不能这样做时，当它无法弄清楚如何理解正在发生的事情、你是谁、外面有什么以及你如何适应它时，那么，它就是在感受精神疾病。而当它在做这件事时，相对准确或准确到足以让你不遇到问题，
that book because I enjoyed her talk. That's another good one if you like things of this vein, and he definitely is a lot smarter than me. But she's saying basically the brain's job is to make order in the world. When it can't do that, when it can't figure out how to make sense of what's happening and who you are and what's out there and how you fit into it, then, it is feeling mental illness. And when it is doing that, relatively accurately or accurately enough for you not to be encountering a problem,
那么这就不是精神疾病。如果你想走更诗意的方向，我可能会这么说。但我认为这个系统是不稳定的，你知道，接着上一篇文章，我不认为它还能维持多久。年轻一代已经在嘲笑治疗师
then that's not mental illness. If you want to go in a more poetic, you know, direction, that's probably what I would say. But I think the system is unstable, you know, to follow up from that last article, I don't think that it can hold much longer. Younger generations are already laughing at therapist
并要求一种新的疗法。他们这样做不是因为他们知道我所说的这段历史。他们这样做是因为他们知道当前的系统对他们不起作用。我们越是沿着证据基础的方向走，并说这是“循证”的，心理健康的结果就越糟糕，我们知道这一点。所以如果我们朝着一个方向前进，而它让人们变得更糟，也许我们的假设是错误的。
and demanding a new therapy. And they aren't doing it because they know this history that I'm saying. They're doing it because they know that the current system is not working for them. The further we have followed the evidence basis in this direction and said that this is evidence based, the worst mental health outcomes have gotten from therapy, and we know that. So if we're going into direction and it's making people worse, maybe our assumptions are wrong.
我们有一本诊断手册，政府自己的研究机构说它在科学上无效。然后有些人会因为你不使用那本书而对你大喊大叫，并称你为“不循证”。你知道，我们有一个职业，在临床医生使用一种范式和研究人员使用另一种范式之间分裂，我们有保险公司要求对维度现实进行分类诊断。他们想要报销的方式可能不是心理学的运作方式。让保险公司告诉你他们偏好的报销方式，然后试图让大脑适应那种范式，绝对是不科学的。所以总会有东西崩溃。问题是何时以及如何崩溃。如果你是一个在政治上感到害怕的人，其中一个
And we have a diagnostic manual that the government's own research agency says isn't scientifically valid. And then you have people who will yell at you for not using that same book and call you not evidence-based. You know, we have a profession that splits between clinicians using one paradigm and researchers using another, and we have insurance companies demanding categorical diagnoses for a reality that's dimensional. And the way that they want to bill may not be the way that psychology works. And letting an insurance company tell you how they prefer to bill and then trying to make the brain fit that paradigm is definitely not scientific. So something's going to break. The question is when and how. And if you're somebody who's scared politically, one of the
问题是谁在负责，不仅仅是总统，而是谁在负责这些科学系统，谁有权力且愿意站出来说话，因为我愿意站出来，但我没有多少权力，伙计。当这件事发生时，因为他们是那个将设定下一个将持续很长时间的范式的人。你知道，波特可能会说，这种转变将发生在经济衰退时，当医疗保健系统面临经济压力，变得无法承受时。当有人决定我们负担不起继续以低效的旧方式做事时。那时他们就会清空棋盘。危险在于，当那一刻到来时，谁处于有利位置，谁就能设计替代方案。
the questions is who's in charge, not just the president, but like who's in charge of these scientific systems and who's willing to speak up that has power, because I'm willing to speak up, but I don't have much power, dude, like when this thing happens, because they're the one that's going to set the next paradigm that's going to last a long time. You know, Porter would probably say that the transition is going to come in a recession when there's economic pressure on health care systems, and that becomes unbearable. And when someone decides that we can't afford to keep doing things in inefficient old ways. That's when they'll wipe the board. The danger is whoever is positioned when that moment comes will get to design the replacement.
而现在，处于有利位置的人不是治疗师，也不是病人。他们是科技公司。他们是制药巨头。他们是保险官僚机构。如果我们不小心，下一个诊断系统将被设计为服务于他们的利益，而不是人类繁荣的利益。所以让我试着总结一下我们现在所处的位置，你知道，在我们结束之前给它定个调。这种批评的一部分并不是说许多关于我们如何诊断的现代假设是错误的。在我看来，问题在于我们拥有的现代神经科学和临床观察，正被DSM-5中固有的、过时的、无意识的和隐含的假设所阻碍。
And right now, the people positioned are not therapists and they are not patients. They are technology companies. They are pharmaceutical giants. They are insurance bureaucracies. If we're not careful, the next diagnostic system will be designed to serve their interest, not the interest of human flourishing. So let me try and summarize where we are here, you know, to put a pen on this before we end. Part of this critique is not that many of the modern assumptions about the way we diagnose are wrong. The problem that, as I see it, is that the modern neuroscience and clinical observations that we have are being held at bay by outdated, unconscious, and implicit assumptions baked into the context of how the system was created and still present in the DSM-5.
剥离了让心理学在治疗室中承认和研究无意识或隐含反应的概念化，这就是我们用CBT所做的，宏观系统本身无法分析那些不是基于证据的、植入其自身系统中的无意识和隐含偏见。因此，学术培训在很大程度上剥离了这种更广泛的背景。治疗师和心理健康专业人员被教导，无论他们在研究生院时什么是循证的或被认为是循证的，那永远就是它将永远是的样子，也是它本应有的样子。我们不需要学习或分析系统，也不需要看看它们是否会改变。
Strip of conceptualizations that let psychology acknowledge and study an unconscious or implicit reaction in the therapy room, which is what we did with CBT, the macro system itself is not able to analyze the unconscious and implicit biases that are not evidence-based that are baked into its own system. And so academic training largely strips this broader context out of what it teaches. Therapists and mental health professionals are taught that whatever is evidence-based or considered evidence-based at the time that they're in grad school is just the way that it will always be and the way that it always should have been. And we don't need to learn or to analyze systems or see if they change.
我们不学习历史和职业内部的辩论。这意味着我们无法诊断我们所处的历史时刻。虽然我们学习诊断，但这真是疯狂的讽刺，对吧？你知道，我再次强调，个体的微观往往就是社会的宏观。出现的同样的心理疾病是由我们居住的世界所解释的。而世界上的许多问题反之亦然，是由
We don't learn history and the debates within the profession. And this means that we're not able to diagnose the point in history, in the history of science that we're in. While we learn about diagnosis, and these are wild ironies, right? You know, again, I make the point a lot that the micro of the individual is a lot of times the macro society. The same mental illnesses that are popping up are explained by the world. that we inhabit. And a lot of the problems with the world are vice versa, explained by the
所有个体中的疾病所解释的。所以这就解释了为什么这么多治疗师在研究生院时继续他们所做的事情，即使他们是在1980年代上的研究生院，他们也不继续自我教育。你会发现一些年长的人只是在他们称之为“循证”但实际上已经错误了20年的范式下运作。继续教育本应阻止这个问题，但它往往只是重复当前的任何概念，它不去寻找这些偏见或分析这些系统。看看我们是怎么走到这一步的。这就是我做这个系列的原因。
illnesses and all of the individuals. And so this explains why so many therapists continue what they're doing when they're in graduate school, even if they were in graduate school in the 1980s, and they don't continue to self-educate. And you'll find older people that are just operating under paradigms that they're calling evidence-based that have been categorically wrong for 20 years. And continuing education is supposed to stymie this problem, but it often just repeats whatever the current conception is, and it doesn't look for these biases or analyze these systems. Look how we got here. That's why I'm doing this series.
我们是否还应该做我们在1950年做的事情？看看像边缘型人格障碍这样的诊断历史。它本质上是三种假设相互矛盾的概念化被嫁接在一起。而这三种概念化，甚至没有人记得它们之间的紧张关系，因为没有人记得历史。坐下来责怪精神药物公司很容易。那并没有错。主要的精神药物公司到目前为止在董事会会议上已经承认，他们宁愿“治疗以维持”，而不是“治疗以治愈”，因为治愈是不赚钱的。
Should we still be doing things that we were doing in 1950? Look at the history of a diagnosis like borderline personality disorder. It's essentially three conceptualizations that contradict each other in assumption grafted together. And the three conceptualizations, no one even remembers the tension between them because no one remembers the history. And it is easy to sit back and blame psychopharmacom companies. That's not wrong. Major psychopharmaceutical companies have admitted at board meetings by this point that they would rather treat to treat, not treat to cure because cures are not profitable.
医疗保健中的利润动机绝对是一种应该通过监管来控制的激励结构，因为它本身并不科学。在许多地方，它与科学背道而驰。然而，这些论点并没有触及系统的根源，也没有理解它。根据我的经验，导致现代DSM问题的不仅仅是这些公认的、你知道的、邪恶的力量。这个问题的真正根源是专业人士的学术不安全感。就像西奥多·波特和尼采所诊断的那样。学者们被教导要捍卫系统。研究心理学家完全生活在这些系统中。当我们把垃圾放入这些系统时，我们就会得到垃圾。即使以错误的方式看待相同的数据也会导致错误的
The profit motive in health care is definitely an incentive structure that should be kept at bay with regulation because it is not in and of itself scientific. In many places, it's at odds with science. However, these arguments do not go to the root of the system and they fail to understand it. In my experience, it's not just these granted, you know, nefarious forces that cause the problem in the modern DSM. The real root of this problem is the academic insecurity of professionals. Like Theodore Porter and Nietzsche are diagnosing. Academics are taught to defend systems. Research psychologists live solely within those systems. And when we put garbage into these systems, we get garbage out. Even looking at the same data the wrong way can lead you to the wrong
故事，精神病学和心理学界需要退后一步，承认他们并不了解一切，因为我们还不知道一切。我们需要调整我们的假设以适应数据，而不是调整数据以适应我们的假设，我们需要在昨天就做到这一点。公众对这些事情的关注度如此之低，是我们处于这种状态的原因之一。最大的科学机构说DSM不再科学，这本应成为全国新闻。根据我的经验，甚至连治疗师都不知道这一点。2013年是DSM-5发布的时间。十多年来，它一直被国内最大的研究机构视为没有证据，而大多数人对此一无所知。DSM从来没有
story and the psychiatry and the psychological establishment need to back up and admit that they don't know everything because we don't know everything yet. We need to adjust our assumptions to fit the data, not the data to fit our assumptions, and we need to do that yesterday. How little the public pays attention to these things is part of the reason why we're in the state we're in. It should have been national news that you had the largest scientific body saying that the DSM no longer was scientific. In my experience, not even therapists know about that. 2013 is when the DSM 5 came out. It's been seen as not having evidence by the biggest research institution in the country for more than 10 years, and most people have no clue. The DSM was never
真正被设计用来描述自然。它是一套军方对什么是正常的假设，而其中太多东西仍然存在。它是一种感觉。它是一套由官僚机构采用、由争取合法性的职业捍卫、并被寻求利润的行业捕获的行政协议，然后它通过牺牲效度实现了信度。它让医生在标签上达成一致，同时忽略了这些标签是否有意义的问题。而NIMH和RDoC是一个诚实的承认，即所有的标签对科学都不起作用。但它也是一种向纯粹唯物主义的退缩。RDoC是什么，是一个研究机器而忽略幽灵的决定。它没有意义的位置，
really even designed to try and describe nature. It was a set of assumptions that people in the military made about what was normal, and too much of that is still there. It was a sense. It was a set of administrative protocols adapted by bureaucracy, defended by a profession fighting for legitimacy, and captured by industries seeking profit, and then it achieved reliability by sacrificing validity. It made doctors agree on labels while ignoring the question of whether the labels meant anything. And the NIMH and RDOC is an honest acknowledgement that all the labels don't work for science. But it's also a retreat into pure materialism. What RDOC is, is a decision to study the machine while ignoring the ghost. It has no place for meaning.
没有叙事的位置，没有人类痛苦体验的位置。它是给神经科学家看的。它对治疗师毫无用处。所以我们留下了一个分裂。DSM是一张没有生物学基础的人类故事地图。RDoC是一张没有人类故事的生物学地图。两者都无法指导治疗。合成会是什么样子？
for narrative for the human experience of suffering. It's for neuroscientists. It's useless for therapists. And so we're left with a split. The DSM is a map of human stories that has no biological grounding. Ardoc is a biological map that has no human story. Neither one can guide treatment. What would a synthesis look like?
是为了叙事，为了人类受苦的体验。它面向神经科学家，但对治疗师来说毫无用处。因此，我们陷入了分裂。DSM是一张没有生物学基础的人类故事地图，而RDoC是一张没有人文故事的生物学地图。两者都无法指导治疗。那么，一种综合性的方案会是什么样呢？
Maybe something like the layered model that I sketched, different frameworks for different kinds of problems with the biological at the bottom and the psychological in the middle and the systemic on the top, like the biopsychosocial model of social work. Maybe something that starts from a definition of health like Goldstein's ability to matter rather than a cataloging pathology. Checklists could work in the synthesis, but they'd have to work forward, not backward. They'd have to start with observations and let categories emerge rather than starting with categories and then forcing observations to fit in them. And they'd have to be tools for organizing knowledge, not substitutes for it.
也许就像我勾勒的分层模型那样，针对不同类型的问题采用不同的框架，底层是生物学，中间是心理学，顶层是系统学，就像社会工作中的生物-心理-社会模型一样。也许可以从戈尔茨坦提出的“健康即重要性”的定义出发，而不是仅仅罗列病理。清单在综合分析中或许有用，但它们必须是向前推进的，而不是向后倒推的。它们必须从观察结果出发，让类别自然浮现，而不是先设定类别，再强行将观察结果塞进去。它们必须是组织知识的工具，而不是知识的替代品。
Nietzsche would say, admit your assumptions. You cannot create a completely logical system as an emotional being. that does not know its own blind spots. Stop pretending the DSM fell from evidence-based practice heaven. It was a product of history and the blind spots of history and the systems and bureaucracies of history that still run our world. If you don't see it as such, you're being a scientific. You're being a child.
尼采会说，承认你的假设吧。作为一个无法洞察自身盲点的情感生物，你不可能创造出一个完全逻辑化的系统。别再假装《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）是从循证实践的天堂掉下来的。它是历史的产物，是历史盲点、历史制度和官僚机构的产物，而这些至今仍在左右我们的世界。如果你看不清这一点，那你就是在伪科学，你就像个孩子。
You're incapable of handling the uncertainty that it takes to be an adult. Stop acting like the categories are carved in nature. Say, this is how we currently think the brain operates. And then be willing to make an assumption that you can't have, numbers and biology for yet. Science isn't a story we tell once and then we repeat forever. It's a process of telling better and better stories of revising our maps when they stop matching the territory. And the DSM has become a story that cannot be revised. A sacred text defended by institutions whose survival depends on it to be true. The story will change.
你无法处理成年人所必须面对的不确定性。别再表现得好像这些分类是自然界刻好的一样。要说：这是我们目前认为大脑运作的方式。然后，要愿意做出一些你目前还无法用数字和生物学来验证的假设。科学不是我们讲一遍就永远重复的故事。它是一个不断讲述更好故事的过程，是在地图不再符合地形时对其进行修订的过程。而DSM已经变成了一个无法修订的故事，一本被那些生存依赖于其真实性的机构所捍卫的圣经。这个故事终将改变。
It always does. It is changing. The only question is whether we'll change it carefully and thoughtfully with attention to what's being lost as well as what's being gained, or we will wait until the whole thing collapses and then scramble to build something new from the rubble. I hope it's the former. I fear it'll be the later. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它总是会改变的。它正在改变。唯一的问题是，我们是会谨慎、深思熟虑地去改变它，并关注在此过程中失去的和得到的东西，还是会等到整个体系崩溃，然后在废墟中仓促重建。我希望是前者，但我担心会是后者。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。